That was mean.
Whoa!
Anyway, whoa!
Hey everybody!
Oh my god, sorry I had to push back the stream a little bit earlier.
Because I woke up and it was like... work.
It was just like... Doki, work messages!
And I was like...
I was just like...
So I had to push back the stream a little bit.
Because I had to deal with work stuff.
Oh my god.
Every day is so, so, so, so busy.
It's been a busy, busy, busy time for me.
But yeah...
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
For those who don't follow me.
My Twitch adventures.
We got third place!
Plus one.
Third place!
In the Pow World Twitch Rivals.
Yeah!
Top three!
Plus one.
Spoiler alert for those who were waiting for the VODs.
I did make a VOD channel.
I linked it on my YouTube channel.
But I do have a VODs channel now.
I'm so sorry for spoiling the people who were waiting for me to upload it onto VODs.
I'm so sorry.
But at least you can...
We'll be able to watch...
You don't know how we got top three.
You know?
So you can watch the process of all of it happening.
It's not like I tweeted it out that I got top three and everything.
But yeah, I want to say a huge thank you for the people at Twitch for inviting me and everything.
You know what was crazy?
Like...
Afterwards, they actually...
I'm pretty sure I can talk about it.
I didn't say it.
Because it's like still in the early...
Like they literally asked me if I was interested.
But like...
Twitch was like...
Do you want to headline a Twitch Rivals?
And I was like...
Huh?
I was like...
Me?
Yeah, they asked me.
They were like...
Do you want to like...
You know how like Twitch Rivals was like...
Twitch Rivals...
Beat...
Pirates...
Stop...
Who organized the Twitch Rivals for me?
Like...
Super Power World?
You know all that?
Like the Fortnite feet...
X Fortnite creator...
Whatever.
They were like...
Do you want to like...
Do one your own?
And I was like...
Fuck yeah!
What?
Me?
I'm just a little old indie Vtuber.
Like...
I was so...
I was so fucking...
Uh...
Surprised.
But yeah, like...
I don't know...
They just wanted to announce it.
And I was like...
Sweet!
Yeah!
I don't know what I'll be doing.
And that sounds pretty fucking cool.
Um...
But yeah...
Like...
A huge shout out to like...
Twitch for the huge support.
I was so...
I was so surprised.
Like...
Honestly...
It's been like...
Super overwhelming...
Every fucking day.
I would say.
It's been...
It's been incredibly overwhelming.
Um...
Seeing all these like...
Companies and like...
Sponsors and stuff.
Like...
Reaching out and stuff.
Being like...
Do you...
Do you want to do this?
And I was like...
Me?
I was like...
You want me to...
To...
To do this?
But then...
I've been like...
Super stressed out.
Because like...
I was like...
I've never had chance to like...
Handle with the money of everything too.
Cause like...
I have a team now.
And then like...
My manager was like...
Uh...
Doki...
We gotta start talking about like...
Payroll.
And like...
Like...
Money.
And I'm like...
Money?
I was like...
Pay...
Payroll?
So...
I was just like...
What...
What do I...
I'm a...
I'm...
Boss?
I'm a...
Boss now?
But...
But like...
I...
I just do.
I just...
I...
I just do!
I don't...
What do you mean?
Pay...
Roll?
I...
I'm so confused.
So...
This is like...
So like...
You are the boss now Doki?
No!
I just want something to take care of me!
I just...
I just wanna do!
I don't want to think about payroll and money.
I just want you I Organize things money disappears.
I don't look at it, but now I have to look at it.
I was like no I have to look at the money
All I want to do is just do That's all I want to do.
I just organize and do fun things And I don't think about the money and now now mr. Matt was like it's time to talk serious adult time with payroll like money wise have budgeting finances as I
like tax returns a payroll staff PR team management team store team sponsors he is like
Adult is so hard PJ thank you for the super Thank you, thank you!
God bless you for bringing joy to so many people and becoming a stronger person.
You deserve your success.
Thank you!
I really appreciate it!
Thank you, thank you!
Taxes, contracts, a lawyer to help with like, like sponsor, like drafting up NDAs.
I was like, drafting up NDAs?!
I was like, oh my god!
Oh my god!
What?!
You're like, you need a Canadian lawyer because you're Canadian.
So you're trapped that handles like business lawyer stuff with NDAs.
I was like, ahhh!
I
was like, oh no!
Anyway, so that was like...
Let's go!
Last night and today.
So I was like...
What does that mean?!
That's... I know!
Like, like Mr. Mad would send me like a whole bunch of information last night.
And then they're like...
And I was just like, I'm going to sleep.
Mr. Mad... Mr. Mad sent me like a bunch of information.
And I was like...
Cause like at first they were like, are you alive?
And I was like, yes.
And then they sent me like a ton of information.
Like, it was like...
And I replied back...
I'm going to sleep.
Future Doki will worry about that later.
Future Doki will worry about this another time.
It was like, I can't.
I'm sorry.
I'm so tired.
I can't.
I cannot make any decision right now.
And then I woke up.
And then it was like...
And I'm just like...
Read.
I was like, unread.
I'm just like, unread.
Okay, stream time.
Super Persona Gamer, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Hey Doki, I'm still like, bringing my birthday today.
Can you sing when everything stays?
No, but I'll sing happy birthday.
I guess I don't know what you're talking about.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Super Persona Gamer.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Yay!
You'll end up becoming your own agency at this point.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Adelus, I'm sorry for future Doki.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
I was actually tempted to like...
Cause like, when I saw the like, giant paragraphs of like, information and stuff I had to do last night.
I was like, oh fuck, should I like, push back today's stream?
And I was just like, no, I really wanna stream.
I wanna run away from my responsibilities for one more afternoon.
So I'm just like, no, I will stream.
I will run away from my responsibilities and pretend that I don't have to do all of that later.
Yay!
Procrastinate!
Please don't be like me.
Please, please do not be like me.
Procrastination is a bad thing.
Okay guys, just, I just, I just need this.
I really, I really need this, guys.
I really fucking need this.
Alright, alright, anyway.
Anyway.
Like, I am the example of things you should not do.
I am, I'm basically like, I'm teaching you what you should not do.
What not to do, guys.
What the fuck?
Why isn't my controller not working?
Do I have to restart?
Fuck, okay guys, sorry.
I have to restart my game.
Because I accidentally, I accidentally went on M and K instead of controller.
And I have not learned how to play this game on mouse and keyboard.
She's just, no!
You don't wanna be just like me, for real, for real!
You have to be, she's just not like me, for real, for real.
Uh, JL, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, Delicious, thank you for the super chat.
Boy, do I get running away from responsibility.
No!
Do not run away from responsibility!
It is bad.
It is so bad.
Right, like right now, I'm trying to pretend I don't have all these responsibilities.
And it's very bad.
It is very, very bad, guys.
Guys, this is not good.
It's not good.
Okay.
I'm here, I'm the, I'm here to teach you guys how not good this is.
Um.
Alright, here, and maybe this time I'll have controller being plugged in.
Come on, Batman.
Why can't I just be a billionaire so I never have to care about payroll?
If I was a billionaire, I'll have so much fucking money that I won't even care.
They'll be like, they won't, they can like, basically, they'll like, write down that I'm paying them like 100k an hour.
And I wouldn't care.
I only have 24%.
I played 5 hours.
And I had 24%?
But anyway, if I was a billionaire, I would not have to care about payroll.
Because they can literally write 100k a day or some shit and I won't care.
Because I'll make back 100k in a day.
Like, they can do whatever the fuck they want.
But sadly, I'm just an anime girl.
I'm just an anime girl.
I can't care.
I have to actually care.
Where am I supposed to go?
We're in the tunnel?
Whoa!
Oh shit, he has a gun.
I just remember how to play.
No!
Shit!
It's okay!
He can't kill me forever!
Oh, they all have guns!
Oh, nevermind!
No!
My one weakness!
Guns!
It's okay.
It's alright.
I didn't realize they all had guns.
Oh, guys!
Look at this.
There's no flashes now.
You see that?
Because I can run mods.
Shoutout to that one Dragoon that linked me, like, the mods thing.
Where...
It actually disables flash.
Oh shit.
Get me back up.
Get me up there.
There's no flashbang anymore.
Thank fucking god.
Holy shit.
Yeah, a Dragoon linked me to a mod that, like, basically disables, like, all the flashbangs.
And thank fucking god.
Oh my god.
I'm so happy.
Wee.
There's no way I can miss.
Please don't look up.
Guys, no, this is...
Guys, I just need you guys to know.
This is very strategic because I purposely made them all together so it's like bullying again.
Please.
Okay, wait, wait.
I'm lining them up, guys!
I'm lining them up, everybody!
Okay?
They're all perfectly lined up now.
And like...
Okay, here you go.
Here we go.
I swear to fucking...
I swear...
Shit!
No!
Please!
Okay.
All right.
Now...
Now they'll be perfectly lined up.
Watch this.
It's like bullying.
There's no way.
I...
I don't know anymore.
No!
I thought you'd last longer.
Look!
Look is it a bad time to tell you guys that I'm not very good at bullying?
Is that...
Hunter thank you for this super chat.
Thank you.
Is it...
Is it a bad time to admit that I was never good at bullying?
Bullying.
Bullying is a lot harder than expected.
Bullying is just as hard as IRL.
Okay, this time.
No way.
At least let me hit one guy.
That's all I ask for.
Please don't look up.
I swear to God.
Wait, how did he get up so fast?
I don't understand.
I swear to God.
I hate this game.
Are you fucking... Okay.
Alright, we're gonna...
Okay, we're gonna do this.
We're gonna do stealth mode.
I might be able to stealth this.
It's stealth.
It's almost stealth.
It's almost stealth!
I did it, guys.
Oh, it was that easy.
Alright.
Thank you, Melissa for the chat.
Thank you.
Finally a streamer that isn't too lazy to install mods.
It's not that we're too lazy to install mods.
It's that we're not allowed to.
Because it's a mod.
Because then we would have to like ask...
Like a lot of times people are like...
It's a mod.
It modified the games.
And usually it wouldn't...
They would be like, no.
But this time...
Because like...
I guess now I'm my own boss.
I don't have to ask anybody.
Look.
See?
I can stealth.
I got this.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Here.
I don't know where to go.
Where am I supposed to go?
Why is there a question mark?
Okay.
The...
Tomato soup.
Ah, BEEAM!
Thank you for the...
Aka soup!
Thank you.
Wait.
What are these question marks?
Are these all the rhythm-y dis shit?
Must be.
What is this?
Warden's mansion.
Obtain.
Destroy.
Obtain the security key codes from the warden.
Locate the warden.
Did I...
Did I not have the security key?
What the fuck was I doing?
Wait.
Did I...
Did I get the security key?
I don't remember.
Find.
Locate.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
I just need to find the...
Okay.
I'm just gonna follow the bloodstains.
Alright.
Here I go.
Is there anybody here?
Oh, shit.
No, don't.
He might be into it.
Oh, the TV.
Oh.
Damn it.
It was too late.
It was too late for the spanking.
God damn it.
Oh, my God.
That's too distracted.
Alright.
Let's go.
We gotta find the warden.
Here we go.
I...
I've like...
I've been...
I was like thinking about...
Wait.
Who's that?
Oh, he...
Is he dead?
I...
And off it goes.
Maybe I'll find somebody randomly.
You know...
I crashed the game.
Guys, it went too far.
It's just too...
The Bataran traveled way too far, guys.
The Bataran...
It went too far out of bounds.
Six.
Thank you, LuciferChat.
Thank you.
Doki is truly a scattered brain burp.
Thank you, LuciferChat.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
It traveled out of game.
They're like, you can't do this.
Yeah.
Bataran was never meant to travel this far.
It went so far.
It just quit the game.
It went further...
It went further beyond.
Oh, my God.
Did you guys see that?
Did you guys hear that, like, they wanted to make a Batman Beyond animated film in the same... from the same studios that did the Spider-Verse movies?
And then Warner Brothers was like, no.
Like, they had, like...
Like, they drafted, like, storyboards and everything.
And then Warner Brothers was like, no.
Yeah!
I was looking at the artwork for it.
It looks so good.
It looks so bad.
Oh, that's why there's wheelchairs everywhere.
Oh.
Okay, where is these fingerprints going?
This way.
What are...
I mean, like, I'm honestly not surprised because Warner Brothers has been, like, you know, shelving a lot of stuff down.
So, like, are you guys really surprised, though, that this side is shelving?
Shove it.
They've been like shelving a lot of projects in general.
So it's not like the first time.
I can just...
What?
Did you do it?
Woah!
What the fuck?
Bro, you could've just killed a random girl!
Bro, that guy could've just killed a random girl instead of his sister.
He doesn't care.
He just hates women, I guess.
Alright, well, there's one... there's no way.
Come on.
NO!
FUCK!
Okay, I'm gonna go ahead!
Woah!
There's no way!
You!
YOU!
Get me... get me out of here.
Okay.
There you go!
It's fine.
I just needed to get rid of the guns.
OH GOD!
Okay, it's fine.
I still remember how to dodge.
I just got rid of the guns.
Oh shit!
Oh fuck him!
Okay.
No gun.
Ow.
It's okay I can regen.
No!
How is he getting guns again?!
Stop!
That's illegal!
Picking up a gun from the floor?
That's so illegal!
If I can't pick up a random gun on the floor, you can't either.
Because they can pick up... No!
If it touches the floor, it's like a five second rule.
And five seconds is already gone.
So like... what's the point of having a five second rule if they can just pick up a gun after five seconds?
Like, come on.
That's not fair.
The floor is like... exactly.
Alright, let me... let me fucking attack this wall real quick.
Boop!
Alright, let me do this.
Yeah, they don't want to get gun cooties.
That's how you get cooties.
Sweet!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I work too hard, but being here is more important.
Who needs...
No!
You sleep!
Sweet!
Don't worry!
There's always the fun!
Sleep is very important.
Sleep is so important.
I still haven't fixed my sleep schedule.
It's been like...
Two weeks and I still haven't fixed it.
Guys, remember to backseat me for the riddles.
I'm too stupid to solve this right now.
This is why Bat... You know what I noticed?
I noticed that all of Batman's robins have like black hair.
So like... it's not random.
I've noticed it.
The kids he's adopting.
It's not random.
He's got a type.
Whoa!
Yeah.
There was the red hair.
Yeah, but like...
We don't really think about that person.
He had it in pre-crisis.
Yes!
But then he dyed his hair.
Hmm...
Because he realized he wasn't...
He wasn't the favorite.
He realized he wasn't...
I'm having a conversation!
I'm so sorry!
Whoa!
Where the fuck did I get shot at?
As I was saying, he realized...
He realized that...
You know, he wasn't getting the same treatment as the other robins.
I mean, he was literally the first one to die.
So like...
At this point, like...
Wow!
The robin that doesn't have black hair...
Dies?
That's...
What a coincidence!
Yeah, it was so rude.
Where am I supposed to go?
I need to...
I already lost the trail.
I was in lot looking at the trail.
Where is it?
Ah, shit!
Where is the DNA?
Oh, there it is.
There is where it goes.
I'm so happy it doesn't have flashbang anymore.
I hated that shit so much.
Uh...
This way?
Okay, there it is.
Oh, has...
Oh!
Structural weakness.
Okay.
Does it really matter if I...
Oh, wait!
I can...
I can collapse this structure.
Alright.
Boop!
How do you not hear that?
Oh, that doesn't matter.
It was just lore.
I returned to my work.
But I could not shake the pictures from my mind.
I should have been repulsed.
But I was more eager than ever to find an explanation for why someone would do this.
Oh, okay.
You hear that?
Uhhh...
You know they don't have guns.
I can just beat them up.
I don't know if they have joker insur...
I actually wonder if the joker actually provides insurance.
Do you guys think the joker would provide insurance?
Cause like I feel like being a henchman is like...
Like such a...
Like it's like literally the only job I feel like.
No?
He could be a good employer.
You don't know that.
Not a chance.
He could be a good employer.
Okay, let me...
Oh shit!
No!
Okay, counter him.
Gotta get this guy up.
Get out.
Get out!
Okay, get him out first.
Like he pays his taxes.
Okay, if he pays his taxes.
He could pay...
He could be paying insurance.
But to be fair, he does employ a lot of henchmen.
So that is a lot of insurance.
Does he offer 401K?
Oh yeah!
Wait, you're alive?
Oh there...
Oh okay, he's just gonna...
Jog off.
Okay.
Bro, I don't think that guy's alive though.
I don't think he's alive.
Alright, which one do we upgrade guys?
Combo boost.
Combo Batarang.
HP.
Batarang power.
Twin Batarangs.
Sonic Batarangs.
Uh...
Okay, these are not available for upgrade.
I don't think.
Oh wait, they are.
Nice.
Take down!
Batarang combo boost.
Okay, combo boost.
Joker pays spikes.
Oh shit.
Neil, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait, I'll get the combo boost.
Are you okay?
Thank you Batman.
The guard wouldn't have lasted much longer.
Is he okay?
He struck his head when they knocked him out.
Oh no.
I'll move him away from here as soon as you can.
Take him to the medical facility.
It's the safest place on the island.
Okay.
I'll go with you soon as I understand.
I feel like a henchman has to be like the most lucrative job there is in Gotham City.
Like there's so many henchmen.
Like there's so many mob bosses too.
It's like...
It's like the only job in Gotham City.
Think about it.
I just noticed.
It's literally like the only job.
Like this entire town is controlled by the mob.
And it's just like...
Like the police is useless.
Why be a cop when you can just be a fucking like underling?
There's no reason to be...
Why be paid like minimal wage as a cop when you can be...
Why be paid like $11 for an hour for a cop when you can be paid like...
I don't know.
Like $100 per hour because you're always going on heists and everything.
Boop.
Nice.
I did that.
No, don't grab the gun.
No, I can't run.
No, don't pick up the gun!
No!
Oh, he's not picking up the gun.
He knows that he respects the five second rule.
Oh, I just punted him.
That's nice.
See, I told you.
I told you.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
That's more than five seconds.
Five seconds!
All right.
Let's get him out.
I need to make sure he doesn't come back.
Oh, yeah.
You think about it.
Batman is sort of like a furry because he's wearing a...
He's wearing an outfit inspired by a bat.
Why is the Junkling obsessed with man and bat?
Is he a furry?
Thank you.
Oh, shit.
My chat died.
Give me a sec.
I need to reload my chat.
He has bat ears.
Yeah.
And he likes Catwoman!
Catwoman is definitely a furry.
If you think about it.
$9 billion fursuit.
No, but you don't understand.
Like, fursuits actually are like a fucking... so expensive.
And he's a billionaire, too!
Oh, my God.
Oh, what?
It fits him.
All right.
Where am I going?
Oh, okay.
That's locked.
Okay.
Wait, what's the riddle?
I don't remember what the riddle was in this area.
Guys, where is the riddle?
Where is the riddle?
I don't know what the riddle was.
I don't remember the riddle.
There's a tape?
Where's the tape?
Tape?
There's no tape here.
You fucking liars.
Where the fuck is the tape?
Oh, it's near the entrance?
Okay, don't worry.
I won't miss the lore.
Oh yeah, do you know there's lore on why he wears his underwear outside of his suit?
I know.
They have lore for everything.
Who's this?
Okay, but like 20 is like nothing in Gotham at this rate.
Where the fuck is this guy?
This is actually a villain I don't know.
He's important enough to have like a voice file, but I'm like, where the fuck is this guy?
Anyway, so the reason why Batman wears his underwear outside of his like...
superhero suit is that it acts as like a...
a filtration device.
So like, I don't remember if it was like gas or whatever.
But like, he can use it to- he can take- so he can take his underwear off very fast.
And use it as like a filtration thing.
Yeah, yeah!
Like to like- to like, you know, put it- put it over his mouth to filter stuff.
And I- I don't- it's obviously bullshit that they invented.
Later on, but like that's like the current lore as to why- as to why he wears underwear outside of his suit.
It's obvious, it's like they invented it just for like- as like a bullshit reason.
But that's like the canon reason why he fucking wears his underwear.
It's like a gas mask.
Yeah, it's like apparently a fucking- like it's apparently a gas mask.
...
Alright, is there anybody here?
I wanna be sure if there's anybody here.
Okay.
Is there anything in here?
What's the sauce for this?
YouTube shorts.
It's always YouTube shorts.
I thought...
Real soft!
How do you reflect on your successes and failures, Batman?
I don't if I don't think about it.
If I never think about it, then I'll never feel guilty.
Yeah, next time I'll be stuck in deadly gas, I'll use my underwear.
Exactly!
We're all learning!
Hello.
Ooh, I don't like two people, one voice, no gun.
Two-face?
Ow!
Wait, what's going on over there?
Is this the laughing gas?
What's going on?
What the fuck is going on?
What the fuck?
Is everything okay?
Is... what the fuck is... what?
What is going on?
Well, this doesn't look too good.
Are they okay?
Wait, how did you die?
They're all locked up.
Return to monkey.
Holy shit, what's going on?
Okay, there's the electricity.
I wonder if there's like anything extra up top.
Is there anything... any loot?
I know there's like a party going downstairs, but... loot?
Supplies can only be used only in a breakout attempt.
This is important!
This is the breakout attempt!
There might be stuff here.
Teeth!
Alright.
Nope.
Can't activate that yet.
Oh!
Taped patient evaluation five.
Victor, yesterday we spoke about the people you killed.
Ah, the zombies.
They are all people, Victor.
Continuously shuttling through the daily grind, waiting for someone to... liberate them.
You mean kill them.
The police report states that you've murdered... or...
Oh, it's twenty... twenty people in this room.
Three months?
That's like... nothing.
In Gotham.
The Joker murders like fifty people a day!
He should be like in the like... the prison.
Like...
He should not be in Arkham Asylum.
Arkham Asylum is where like... the grade A villains...
Like rookie numbers, exactly.
It's okay.
It's fine.
It's like it.
I
can make it happen.
Yeah, he has such a fucking low body count.
He is not... he is not fit.
He's not Arkham Asylum material.
This is why nobody remembers him.
Twenty people in like three months?
Like, if I was allowed to kill... I'm pretty sure I've killed like a hundred today.
It's still...
The thing is...
Like...
It might have... it might have been like one week since we played... we started playing this game.
But all... like... all right now... like for Batman... it's still like maybe two hours have passed for Batman.
And like... if we're going by Batman time... if I was allowed to kill in Batman...
I'm pretty sure I've killed a hundred people in Batman.
Within two hours in Arkham Asylum.
I'm... I'm just saying.
That's why this is like... who the fuck cares about Mr. Zazz?
Why the fuck do we put him in like the grade A... the grade A... um... asylum?
Oh wait, is this it?
Oh, now this is too small.
There you go.
Two people, one voice, one... there has to be two...
Oh, that's a ventricle request?
Arnold Wesker was a timid orphan whose deep regression...
erupted in a barren brawl.
Resulting in him being sent to Blackgate Prison.
There he encountered a puppet Scarface and...
Oh yeah, he's like a mob boss son or something.
And probably murdered a man who carved the puppet.
The two are now inseparable with a Scarface directing a series of criminal activities.
While most believe that Wesker is simply acting out a second personality through the puppet.
Wesker sees himself as a reluctant lackey who merely does his parents' bitty.
What's his... what's his size?
What's his height?
5'7".
Professional criminal.
Nice.
Oh wait, he has facts!
Wait, I wanna know about his life!
Alright.
Delusional, schizophrenic...
Oh, he didn't take his meds.
Obsessed with his puppet Scarface whom he puppeteers with...
This...
Wait...
Do we just have a mental health problem in Gotham City?
When teen was...
If we give the criminals, like, actually meds...
Do you think they'll be better?
Like...
I don't know.
Batman!
You could have stopped all this if you improved the mental health system!
In Gotham City instead of running around in your underwear and buying underwear gas masks!
Alright, I guess we leave here.
Probably not.
Who needs YouTube shorts for Batman lore?
I use Doki Batman shoes for getting the lore.
Go Zeta, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
He is Gotham's biggest serial killer after Joker.
Yeah, yeah, he is definitely Gotham's biggest serial killer after Joker.
Thank you for the super chat, Zeta.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, is that Poison Ivy?
Poison Ivy!
Stop!
Really
not interested in a bunch of flowers, Ivy.
They're in pain!
Cry for help!
Ooh!
Where are your babies?
Just stay where you are.
Last thing I need is you running out of- Just stay- how is she gonna get out?
I'll save you.
Just stay where you are.
Like, she's- where is she gonna go?
Botanist Pamela Isley was transformed by a science experiment gone wrong into a plant-human hybrid.
With chlorophyll flowing through her veins instead of blood, she developed a toxic touch and a pheromone-fueled talent for seduction.
Her crimes have become more ecologically focused as she has increasingly abandoned her human side, identifying more with the natural world.
Her unique brand of ecoterrorism often puts her in a conflict with Batman, whose iron will usually protects him from her seductive powers.
She's not hot enough, I guess.
It's just not his type.
Five foot- wait, she's taller than the ventriloquist.
...
An ability to encourage and direct the growth of all plant life, plant genes mixed into her DNA makes her an unpredictable and formidable physical opponent.
Exudes natural pheromones that enable her to exert control over victims.
Okay.
Are you crying?
Wait, why is she wearing a shirt?
I mean- I meant that in a way where like, her clothes are her plants.
You know?
I didn't mean that in any other way.
Because look, look, she's not wearing a pink-red shirt here.
I'm saying it because she's wearing a red shirt.
But like, she's not wearing a shirt here.
Like, her clothes are plants.
And that's not a plant.
It's not like in any- it's not a perfect way!
I'm not saying it in a perverted way!
I'm saying it as a lore way.
That's not a part of her!
It's red!
That's not a natural plant!
I'm just saying!
It's not- it doesn't fit lore!
According to the lore!
Her shirt should be green!
Alan, you said what everyone wanted.
Shake my head.
They're all like little monkeys!
Who's they?
Okay.
A case of mistaken identity.
What?
Who?
Who's that?
Is that Garrd?
Wait, what?
Is Quincy?
Oh, Aaron?
You need to get me out of this cell.
It's me Cash!
You've been like useless so far though.
Why would I need your help?
Harley?
Why is she wearing a shirt?
No!
Ivy!
I told you to stay in there!
Ivy, what the fuck?
I'm a good kid.
Whoa!
They're just really good friends, yeah.
Guys, they're just best friends.
Ow!
No!
I wanted to scare him!
Yeah, they're roommates.
No!
I wanted to scare him for Clayface!
Just gals being pals.
Alright, I guess we'll rescue you.
It's like the Sailor Moon English dub, where they're like, they're just cousins.
Wow, they're such good cousins to each other.
Broke and used my 512 bit decryption key.
Use ultrasound to bypass security systems.
Oh my god, I can finally do this!
There's always a way out.
Always.
My fists will make the way out.
Which one is it?
This one.
Okay.
Here?
Boop.
I'll just shoot the problem.
Oh, never mind.
What?
What am I doing?
What the fuck am I doing?
Is that hacking?
Is this...
Oh, I make it green!
Wait, oh, he changed.
Clayface.
I'm losing patience.
You're cheating.
Alright.
Initially an actor in horror films, Kylo went mad when he learned a classic film of his was to be remade with a different actor in the lead role.
He took on the mask of the film's villain, Clayface, and killed several of the remake's cast and crew before being slaughtered.
He was stopped by Batman and Robin.
Later, Kylo joined a mud pack, an alliance of shape-changing, mutated villains who had subsequently used the name Clayface.
While the group was defeated, Kylo tricked his allies and injected himself with the essences of several of them.
Becoming a superhuman imbued with the ability to change shape, he just wants to be an actor.
That's all.
He doesn't want... oh, he must be like really old too.
Because he was... he got casted.
Oh yeah, any fun facts?
Six push five.
Professional criminal.
He can alter his physical form, adopt the appearance of nearly anyone.
His mouthful, his touch can be poisonous.
Wait, what is he doing with that doll?
Clayface?
Clayface, where are you?
What are you doing?
What are you doing with this little doll?
I'm just curious, Clayface.
Like...
Whoa!
Again!
Is that it?
I don't think he knows Commissioner Gordon.
I...
I don't think he knows like...
I don't think he's like met Commissioner Gordon.
He definitely hasn't really studied this role yet.
Again!
Aww, no more magic tricks.
No more.
The commissioner who laughs.
He probably only saw him on TV.
Yeah, he probably has.
He doesn't know like what he actually does.
Oh, riddle me this.
Nice.
Riddle me this.
Fake fan.
Wait, if I talk to him, will he...
Will he change back?
No.
Aww, look there's another wheelchair!
Like I'm pretty sure there's not a lot of people who are...
Who are like...
Who need that wheelchair.
I think it's just Joker trying to convince someone to do stuff.
He break...
I don't want to break the glass.
Why the...
What the fuck?
Who's your arm?
Is it inside?
Who are you?
Oh, riddle me this.
Can I...
Can I hack this?
Oh, can I hack this?
I can!
It's hacking time.
Yay!
Are you okay, sir?
I'm okay.
Intensive treatment extreme.
Han, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
In the morning, I have a competition later, but watching a stream is more...
No!
You have to win for me!
Han, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You have to win for me!
Go to sleep!
Oh no, Poison Ivy's out.
Alright.
Where are the enemies?
Enemy?
Wait, riddle me this.
Okay, this is more important.
Yay!
XP.
What do I have to do?
Destroy the Titan production facility and botanical gardens.
Okay, I need to get to the botanical...
What the fuck is the botanical?
Okay, I have to go outside.
I have to go touch grass now.
Jesus Christ, get over here.
Alright,
let's see.
Ooh!
Okay.
I need to mark this.
One punch.
Like, I wish he did not have a single plan for this.
He did not have a fucking plan.
How do I do this?
Or just hack this?
Wait, can I hack this?
No.
Fuck.
Wait, how the fuck do I get over there?
It's so far!
What if I just...
Oh, later?
Okay, not yet.
Okay.
When you say later, it means I'm never coming back here.
You know damn well I'm never coming back.
I always thought there was a spark between us.
Bro, how...
From how many people?
From now, there is.
Oh, no!
Hey, that just meant...
Come and get me, Bats!
I double dare ya!
Oh, shit.
Where am I?
Oh, fuck!
Can't go back!
Oh, wait, I can go up.
You guys are idiots!
They're got to everywhere!
Nice.
You're dead!
God damn it!
Can you hear me, man?
Get up here.
It's not fair!
Oh, shit!
Oh, shit, he's grabbing a gun!
Somebody stop him!
I'll stop him!
There you go.
Nice.
Yeah, just run away.
All right, here's you.
Wait, there's more?
Sorry.
If you all stay near me, it's like bowling again.
Just punch around on me!
If you don't, I'll shoot you.
Eventually!
Eventually it'll all hit you.
I love buddy mashing.
It's my favorite part about fighting games.
Am I doing it?
Am I pressing Y and B?
Nice.
Last guy.
Goodbye!
I'm doing it.
Was that as easy as it looked?
Huh.
Well, it won't be so easy trying to catch me.
Mwah!
I mean...
If I actually shoot you, it'd be easier.
I feel like why wouldn't I have tranquilizer guns?
Like, what are my Batman gear that's just not just fist and bat around?
I feel like it'd be easier to have a tranquilizer and I can just tranquilize villains.
Because I can't kill.
But... I can like... put them to sleep.
If I put them in a coma, does that count as killing?
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
It's 11pm.
I have nothing planned tomorrow, but Doki's stream is more important.
Thanks for the EU friendly time!
It's up to you!
And once again, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
It's no problem.
I only do a longer stream today for Batman because I realize I am very behind in Batman.
If I put them in a vegetable state, is that also killing?
This rule sucks, Batman!
This rule fucking sucks!
Because like, putting them in a vegetable state is almost practically the same thing.
Oh, wait, let me hack this.
Yes!
But technically I'm sort of doing it already.
I can't even think about it.
There we go.
This is...
If I was... If I made this, then it wouldn't be hacking because I made it.
Okay, I'm a little lost right now.
It's arguably worse.
Like I'm practically... Oh yeah, me punching those henchmen in the head is not technically putting them in the vegetable state.
Like...
Okay, I'll make sure like everything I got...
It's locked.
What?
I thought I hacked everything.
Let's do the hack.
Oh, were those upper level?
I already got that.
That's the gun.
You're just...
Putting them in dream realm.
Oh, there it is.
I didn't hack this.
Wait, what?
No, I hacked that.
I'm just gonna beat this guy up real fast.
Monkey.
Get over here.
Let me kill this guy first.
Nice riddle.
You're standing in the way with my riddle.
Alright, here you go.
No punch monkey.
Didn't I hack everything?
What else do I have to hack?
I thought I hacked everything.
I'm just tucking... Yeah, I'm just tucking them into bed.
Yeah, I hacked this.
Hacked that.
Wait, there's something below me.
Oh no, no, not that.
Hacked the bodies.
This is not PAL World, guys.
Did I hack this?
No.
Where the fuck do I need to go?
The door is locked.
I'm chasing Harley.
Yeah, but the doors are locked.
I hacked everything.
I think?
I forgot where he ran... she ran to.
I blew up a wall?
I'm just like...
When did I do that?
I'm so confused.
Where I got the last trophy.
I'm so lost.
This is why I need a robin.
Robins!
Where are you?
Go straight to the side.
This one?
Where are my robins?
Oh wait, this way.
That's me here.
Prometheus, Arkham God, most wanted and most hated.
Wait, there's someone more hated than fucking Batman and Joker?
No way.
Really?
Let me do this.
Try using your...
No!
I don't need eyes when I have chat.
Who's my favorite robin?
What if I just let them die?
I didn't kill him.
Gravity killed him.
Oh.
I have to save...
.
What?
Why do I have to save them?
Oh yeah.
Those two guards are the most important guards.
And I can just hire new ones.
That's cool.
Like, there's so many guards have died already.
Like, at this point, it's just...
I don't really care anymore.
Okay.
Okay, you do your exposition.
I'm going to do this.
It's not my fault.
Wait, what?
Wait, where's the other one?
That's Batman.
Oh no.
Oh no!
No, I don't do all the pressure!
It's okay.
No, it's not okay!
No!
I thought I could... I thought I could do it... I thought I could just do it before it comes back up.
Okay, I'll let her do her exposition.
I didn't think she was gonna turn it on again so fast!
Alright, let her do her exposition this time.
Okay.
Hacked.
No!
I don't like pressure!
Please.
Please!
Don't turn it back on!
I'm stuck in the cutscene!
There you go.
Done.
What?
How?
I don't do well on...
Hack the door?
Oh shit!
Alright, 11 seconds I can do this.
Why do you have to take so long to break?
I'm gonna go get fucking hacking things!
There you go.
Get out!
Nice.
I'm so good at this game.
Not even close.
And then her girlfriend.
And then the other boyfriend.
And then...
Can I go back inside now?
Can I go back inside?
Oh wait, that's not the inside.
It was this way.
Is it locked forever?
No!
It's locked forever!
Wait, where do I go?
Where do I go?
It's really...
Just like...
Where?
Here?
Oh, there's a hack.
Must be a hack here too.
Alright, this way.
It's not... Oh, there you go.
Yay!
This may take a while.
The system's locked me out.
Oh shit, this is the... the gas chamber.
Wait, it was a real gas chamber this entire time?
Hey, welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Okay.
Oh wait, I can go up.
Nice.
What do I do up here though?
I can go up, but what's the point?
Really?
Let me do this!
Okay, I need to blow this up.
Uhhhh...
There you go.
Surely nothing bad's gonna happen.
I'm underwear.
Yeah, see?
Oh no, that's still the gas.
Wait, but where's the question mark?
How do I do this?
Nooooooo!
Nooo, it's so far!
I can't turn the fan off!
Come back later?
That's code for I'm never coming back.
Backtracking?
Nah...
Let's see...
I guess we go back here.
Room is the end of days for even the most celebrated killer.
What's that mean?
Bro, I'm on detective mode.
Can I get cancelled for beating up...
For beating him up?
Goddammit, Batman!
This is not good!
They need medical help!
Wait, who's that over there?
Come on!
Oh.
Oh no, he's dead.
More teeth!
Teeth!
Teeth is important.
I guess here, right?
Oh!
Who has four walls, two sides, and one X-DNA?
I actually don't know who that is.
Alright.
Who dat?
Did I already do this?
I already did this hack.
Oh well, get over there.
So I can beat him up.
Is that Two-Face?
Where Two-Face?
Security guard.
Oh!
How do I get this out?
Wall...
Wall mounted and held with...
Okay, I can't do that.
Obviously.
I'm so confused.
Look for his old cell.
Oh dead!
There it is!
That's his cell!
District Attorney Harvey Dent was one of Batman's strongest allies in Gotham City.
Until the criminal threw acid in Dent's face, headlessly scarring him.
The wounds fractured his psyche and he was born as a schizoid criminal mastermind, obsessed with duality.
His former good luck charm, a two-headed trick silver dollar, was damaged on one side in an attack, and Dent has seized on it as a reflection of his half scarred visage.
On it as a reflection, he flips it to decide the fate of his victims.
Despite Batman's effort to reform his former ally, Dent is consumed by his fixation on chance, and his crimes are designated to design to prove out his diametric philosophy.
Alright, how tall is he though?
The most important question.
How tall is he?
Headlessly scarred on the left side when she plays out with Chloe, that's definitely solid.
It's not like... oh I thought it was like a fun fact, but it's just an attribute.
The question, how tall is he?
Where'd that go?
I'll always be last.
I'll never ever figure out where to go.
Do I stay here?
Clawgate?
Oh my claw!
I have so many... God!
Batman has so many gadgets.
I forgot.
Bro, I never use this.
Oh my god, his other... his useful tools.
Wow!
Where did... how did you get over here?
What the fuck?
Please don't cancel me.
He... it was self-defense.
It's him again.
Bro, he's depressed because he can't kill.
Bro, we all want things, alright?
It's part of growing up.
Sometimes you don't get what you want.
Mofo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Do you think Batman sends people to Arkham Asylum knowing that they'll escape just so he could be...
I think he has anger issues.
I think like he just wants to beat up his problem instead of actually rehabilitating.
Like, investing in like proper mental care to these people.
Like, majority of the criminals here are just like mentally unwell.
Like, there's literally like six nurses.
Like, six nurses in the entire Arkham Asylum.
And like, I feel like, you know, maybe if they have more nurses, you know?
Maybe if Arkham Asylum, a asylum, a mental hospital, assign more medical professionals, things would be a little better.
Instead of six nurses.
If you think about it, like, that's the biggest issue I have with Batman.
That's why I'm like lagging by like crazy for some reason.
I'm like, like 30 FPS at the moment.
Give me a sec.
I'm like 30 FPS for some fucking reason.
Oh my god.
You know what?
Give me a sec.
Let me reset this.
Six nurses, electrical bill of one million.
Let's see.
Whoa.
Why am I lagging so badly?
Maybe if I...
Okay, let me reset this real fast.
Like, there's a lot of like issues with Gotham.
Because like...
Gotham in general just has...
It's not really the perfect city.
But yet like, for some reason, Gotham has like so many billionaires.
Maybe Gotham is like Texas.
In a way that like taxes are like...
The tax...
It's like...
It's like the taxes are really like barely existent in Gotham.
So like all the billionaires live...
All the billionaires live there.
I think like...
Maybe like...
The servers are like extra...
I'm like semi...
It's alright.
We're just gonna go retro.
Like I'm saying it's like Texas and more so like the tax...
There's like barely taxes in general.
So then like...
That's why all the billionaires live in Texas.
Not Texas.
All the billionaires live in Gotham.
Hahaha.
Alright, what do we upgrade?
There's batteram power, twin batteram, sonic batteram, multiple...
Sonic batteram?
What does a sonic batteram do?
Okay, what does it do?
I swear to god you're making me upgrade a dumb...
Tune the resonant exact frequency nearest attracting the useful for luring a target into a trap or away from an area.
One throw requires a short recharge period for the target.
If we can get the target to use the thing that we want to.
Oh, it lures them.
Why would I need to lure them?
I can just beat them up.
I guess I can use the lure...
I don't have any traps though.
Alright, we'll do it.
Fine.
I'll do it.
Alright.
Is this another...
Where I'll go?
Up?
Scalem, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
$100 nurses.
What is it?
I mean,
Batman is willing to just throw away like his fucking car so easily.
And that car is like, I would not be surprised if it's like a hundred million dollars.
Like I would not be surprised at a hundred million dollar car right there.
He doesn't care!
Hey, we're gonna need this.
Stop buying bad themed gadgets.
No.
They're not even great gadgets too.
Oh yeah, I didn't see the hack here.
I hate the argument of like, how much prep time does Batman need?
And people will be like, who's gonna win Batman vs X?
And people will be like, how much prep time does he get?
Well, sometimes people don't get prep time.
Majority of the time, people will never get prep time.
If you think about it.
Usually when something happens, it sometimes comes by surprise.
Why are we giving him prep time?
A good villain would never give you prep time!
It's always a surprise!
Where?
Oh, there.
Alright.
Give me a sec.
Let me beat up some people real quick.
Oh, nice!
That's fucking right.
Get down!
Oh shit!
Electricity!
Oh!
My floor is lava!
Floor is lava!
Alright, get out of here.
It's fine.
We're fine here.
It's not this floor.
Alright, let's heal.
Oh my god, where the fuck...
Oh, please!
That's so long!
Get me out of here!
Oh my god, that's so scary.
That's so fucking scary.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Get me out!
Nice.
That's right, you can't fuck with me, Harley.
I like how they're just waiting there.
It's like, Harley, can we play now?
Can we?
Even the goons are like, move.
I like how they're like, can we come play now with Mr. Batman?
Is it time now?
Oh fuck.
I thought I got them.
Don't let him... just don't get hit!
Oh!
Get out!
Oh shit!
There we go.
I need to like...
Oh shit, no!
Why are you letting yourself get hit then?
Oh shit.
Get me out!
Oh, I hate that.
I'm so bad at this one.
Okay.
There we go.
Nice.
That should be the last... nope, that's not the last guy.
Okay.
Alright.
We need the regen!
Guys!
No!
It's the electricity guy!
Oh!
It's okay.
I have a plan.
Okay, it was not this.
No!
He can just kick me like that!
Okay.
I got a plan, guys.
I got a plan.
There we go.
I got a plan!
If I keep running back and forth!
Don't worry, I got a plan.
Trust the process.
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Trust the plan!
There we go.
No, no, no, no!
Woah!
Yes!
Okay.
Okay!
We're fine!
No, no, no!
Oh god, we're fine!
We're fine!
Why didn't you be in a dream?!
I should have given him more prep time.
What's up, kiddo?
But I tried my best!
Sorry, but there is no prize for second place!
I'm afraid to rob the party list.
What the fuck?!
Next time!
You're just gonna do that to a party like that?!
No!
So here she has Ivy.
Her best friend and roommate.
We've been easy with prep time.
I'm not gonna let you do that!
Wait, who's that?
Why the smile's next to certain names?
Yeah.
You're the detective?
You tell me!
No backseat me, Harley.
Just punch her in the head like all the other ones!
What?
You won't hit a woman?
She killed more people than the Joker goons!
You were fine, Mr. J!
He's in the secret lab in the gardens and...
Oh crap!
Yep, I know.
You nearly killed more than the other guys!
What the fuck?!
It should be equality!
Oh, she's crying.
So you can find the secret lab in the gardens?
Yes.
Harley's been everywhere on the island.
So I'm calibrating the scanner to only show prints that have traces of chlorophyll.
Okay, listen.
Be careful.
I rerouted a way...
I can fix her, but she's hot!
We're showing up hot.
Something bad is happening there.
I don't think she's fixable.
Guys, I don't think she's fixable, guys.
I don't think... I'm gonna use the backdrop to be right back.
I don't
think she's fixable.
Alright, I'm back.
Can you guys still fix her?
I can fix her with enough prep.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm saying is that I'm okay with giving these guys fucking concussions.
But like Harley who has killed so many people in two hours.
I just put her in a fucking...
cell.
I just put her in a fucking prison cell.
Like what is this?
Check the ice cell?
There's an ice cell?
There's more than one?
Boy, there's so many shit going on.
I beat up so many people.
Holy fuck.
Oh, there it is!
Oh!
There you go.
I see it.
Mr. Freeze.
Victor Fries was a brilliant cryogenesis whose beloved wife Nora was stricken with a fatal degenerative disease.
He placed her in suspended animation while obsessively searching for a way to cure her.
The corporation that funded his research and Nora's life pulled the plug, triggering an accident that transformed Fries' body into a cold-blooded form that must always be kept below zero.
At normal room temperature, he will die.
Wearing a number of freezing weapons, he wears protective armor in his quest to somehow bring back his lovely wife and avenge her fate, which he partly holds the Batman responsible for.
What the fuck did Batman do?
Was he the one that like pulled the funding?
Marcus, thank you for the future...
Thank you for the future chat.
Super chat.
Thank you.
I can fix it.
Just trust the process.
Oh yeah, what are the fun facts?
How tall... what is the most empowering fact?
How tall is he?
Six feet.
Alright, professional.
Specialty.
Employees.
Extensive.
Wait, what?
What about his wife?
What's that about his wife?
Motivates grief and anger.
Oh shit, by spite, just like me!
For real, for real.
Let's see.
Oh, nice.
Jesus Christ, that's a lot of bodies.
I submit you.
Thank you for the super chat, Terminator.
Thank you.
Alright, is there anything over here?
Oh, it just should be.
Yeah, there should be a video.
What is he saying?
Oh shit!
How
the fuck is he stronger than the guard?
I would assume the guard is stronger than the guard.
The guards are more trained than him.
He's literally in an asylum.
There's no way.
There's no way he's getting the proteins necessary to keep up his muscle.
Poor Bill.
Poor me.
Hiring these god awful guards.
Alright, hacking time.
Wait, what?
Can I hack?
Currently inactive.
Oh, they're all inactive.
Oh wait, no, except for this one.
I guess it's sort of like prison.
I mean, it is prison where they train.
All they do is fucking get buffed as fuck in prison and lifting weights and stuff.
I feel like if I was the warden of Arkham Asylum, I would not buy a gym.
Yeah.
I would be like, why the fuck would I give prisoners time to train and get buffed?
You fat ass caught in my trap!
No!
I'm so stu- Oh wow, never mind.
I got trapped by riddles!
This is why you should not be a completionist.
Oh.
Nice.
They brought the animal before me.
Shameless and barking like a mad dog.
For what felt like days, I endured his boasts.
He took pleasure recounting his actions.
Cataloging his depraved crimes.
What should have been revenge turned to pity.
This poor dog needed my help.
Oh?
Wait, how do I get up?
Oh wait, there.
Wrapper!
Nice.
Okay, now...
Now I go...
I missed Calendar Man's cell?
Which one is Calendar Man's cell?
God, there's so many fucking bodies.
Wait, all I'm saying is that I would never have...
Like, I would never...
Have a gym...
For my prison.
Because I do not want them to get buff.
Like, what's the point?
Why am I training them to be like...
Better people?
Why am I training them to be buff people to kill again?
Like, I think that's stupid.
Where do I go?
I'm sick.
Track Harley's fingerprints where?
Where?
Where is her fingerprints?
Do I...
Do I go back?
Oh, wait, is that door?
That's a door!
Wait, no.
No, wait.
Wait.
Oh, no.
Do I go backwards?
I must go backwards.
There's nowhere else to go.
What did you touch, Harley?
Oh, yeah, it's backwards.
Okay.
It's backwards.
That Arkham Isle.
Okay, I got it.
I figured it out.
It's up here.
We're always lost.
That's my secret chat.
Alright, this way.
This way.
Oh, God.
I was not... I did not realize that was a gift.
There's the loose cap.
She did an okay job.
Let's call it a deal.
But between you and me...
I'm aiming for the A grade.
Just go to mix a couple more of these chemicals, and I'll be creating my own personal army.
Ha!
I guess you don't have to pay them, too.
Because they'll be too stupid to want money.
If you, like, expose them to the chemicals.
That's pretty smart.
What do you think about there's so many riddles?
I'm just going to pretend I didn't see it.
Oh!
This is Calendar Man!
So, where's Calendar Man?
Look at that!
See, guys?
I'm not that stupid.
I recognize this riddle for Calendar Man.
Okay.
No, Joker apparently pays really well because he doesn't do shit for money.
Like, he does this for, like...
He doesn't care about money.
So, he actually pays really, really well.
Because he doesn't care about the money that he gets.
From the heist.
All he does...
He cares about is mayhem.
So, he gives away all the money...
To his...
Yeah, it's about the message.
So, he pays...
He's actually a really nice boss when it comes to the money.
Not the other stuff, though.
The other stuff is different.
But, like...
Oh, there it is.
This has to...
Hey, guys!
Where do you guys think is Calendar Man's cell?
Do you think it's the one filled with calendars?
Uh...
Calendar Man!
God, that outfit is so stupid.
Fixated on the calendar, Julian Day became Calendar Man.
A villain who timed and tied his crimes thematically to certain holidays throughout the year.
Often leaving clues by which he could be caught.
Gotham City's hopes for a day off are often clouded by the knowledge that...
any holiday of note is likely to be shadowed by Calendar Man's presence.
Then, like...
Don't release him on holidays!
On holidays, you put him on house arrest!
Because he has a pattern!
Gotham!
Just put him on house arrest on holidays!
Don't have a holiday in Goth...
You know what?
Just don't have a holiday in Gotham City!
He escapes, obviously.
Well, cap him on 24 hours of...
There's not enough holidays in the world.
Guys.
There's...
First off, there's not a lot of holidays.
So you can use one day on...
You can use the holidays to...
to fucking...
Make sure he doesn't escape.
As he's getting away with...
with...
this...
Just go somewhere else!
Clearly, his only crime is in Gotham City!
So have a vacation outside of Gotham!
What about birthdays?
Okay, I don't think Calendar Man gives a fuck about birthdays, guys.
That's not a holiday.
Your boss is not gonna give you a holiday.
Because it's your birthday.
Don't fucking...
Guys.
Guys, you go to work on your birthday.
Welcome to adult life.
I'm sorry.
You're fucking working on your holiday, guys.
Stop talking.
That is definitely news.
We don't have proof, but he's definitely dead.
I like how someone was like...
Badoki, my birthday is on summer break.
I hate to break it to you.
But like...
For some jobs, there's no summer break.
In the adult world.
Okay, let's see.
We have to go this way.
No, don't tell him.
No, don't tell him that!
No!
Please.
I'm trying to talk to him.
I'm trying to talk to my chat, sir.
Why would you tell him that?
Wait, is he stuck?
I thought he was, like, stuck in the fucking...
Stuck in the wall.
Wait, can I open this?
Oh, shit.
I can.
Wait.
Open.
Oh, I can be here too.
I can be just like you, sir.
No.
Santa is real.
Don't worry.
At least that's one thing we can count on.
Santa is a mutant in the X-men.
Is that a wrap?
Thank you.
Oh,
so like, you're not rather... like, I don't care about these guys now being out.
Because they're like, weaker than the other goons.
Oh, do you think there's...
Alright, this should be...
Do I have to unlock more in the Easter egg time?
Let me check.
Madison, think of a super chat thinky think.
Oh!
He has a different pose now!
He's so quirky.
Which one?
Well, there's a reason why I have like, five hundred robins.
I'm done playing with you right now.
Time for a new robin.
Alright, let's see.
These guys are so fucking weak.
Like, I just slap him once.
Like, I'm just like, am I supposed to be scared of these guys?
I'm not gonna have like, the regular Joker goons.
The regular ones are at least more of a challenge.
These guys are just... it's just sad.
Oh, wait.
Wait, what?
Oh shit, what the fuck is going on?
Oh, it's this side.
How did they beat up the guys with guns?
They're literally one shot!
How did you die?
They're so weak!
Help!
I'm too strong.
They have guns!
Okay, it's this way.
Wow.
Oh my... this is sad.
I'm... this is so sad.
Please stop.
This is too sad.
It's...
Dogs are supposed to get harder, not easier.
Come on.
What a... Joker, you fucking fell off.
Like, the fact that it just takes one hit is... that's the saddest part.
What's the riddle?
I already forgot the riddle.
It's the free XP.
Thank you for the free XP.
The fuck is the riddle?
Batman is too strong.
Wait, deceased?
Oh no, he's okay.
These guys are deceased.
In the graveyard?
Oh, it's on the other side.
Okay.
I thought like... it was like... uh...
Okay, I thought it was like in that little hole that we're in.
Alright, come over here.
Teeth!
There you go.
Alright, we're gonna go to the gardens.
Poison Ivy!
I'm coming over!
Teeth!
Is the number up to the guards?
Oh.
Not botanical tab?
Oh no, it is the botanical tab.
Okay, locate.
Tracker thing.
Oh, there's your finger.
Wait, did she touch the floor?
Why the fuck did you touch the floor?
Oh, maybe she's like doing cartwheels, you know?
Maybe.
Wait, are they dead?
Oh, I was like...
Oh, how nice, they're reading books.
Why is she touching so many floors?
Okay.
Watch this.
Wait, wait.
Come on.
It worked!
It's won!
One is something!
It's that easy.
Nice.
Is the number up?
You were ready to impress me, Batman.
You may still reach a level just below my genius one day.
What the fuck?
What did you say?
Scrubs, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Please put me in a vegetable state so Poison Ivy will love me.
Okay...
That's pretty good.
Poison Ivy will never love you.
Alright, what do we upgrade, guys?
What's the best upgrade to get?
I missed the tape.
Where's the tape?
Oh, tape on the bench?
Okay.
You have to face reality right now!
She's never gonna love you!
You're not a plant!
Even if you're a vegetable state, you don't have any greens in you!
The twin Bataran?
Okay, I'm gonna get the twin Bataran.
Combo Bataran?
What the fuck is Combo Bataran?
Oh shit, nice.
I'll do that.
I wanna plant, mommy.
Fucking date a florist!
It's less lethal!
There's no fucking...
There's no tape here.
Oh, there's tape here.
It's not the same!
It's a bigger world!
Alpha,
you tried to kill everyone in Gotham.
Well sometimes you need to broom back hard in order to make something flourish.
To be fair, if she was a real eco-terrorist, she would not be aiming for Gotham City.
Because she could just aim for the oil rigs in the ocean.
That's like owned by the entire... like by private corporations that's not in Gotham City.
What?
Not a real eco-terrorist.
Fucking rookie.
She's just a rookie.
You gotta start small.
If she wants to change the world!
She should not be aiming for small.
Poser.
What a fucking poser!
Where the fuck...
There you go.
She's like those fucking...
Those ones that threw paint on the Mona Lisa.
Oh wait, I almost ran this way.
They're just trying to get more...
The whole idea is that any publicity is good publicity.
So like...
Do they have guns?
Oh they do.
That's scary.
Oh that's a lot of them.
Or sorry, soup.
They threw soup at the Mona Lisa.
Because their idea is that any publicity is good publicity.
So they're like...
Oops.
Fuck that!
Ah shit!
Fly, fly, fly!
It's okay.
They always forget.
But like...
It doesn't really work like that.
Wait there's...
Bullying!
Okay wait, I can blow it again.
Don't worry, I can blow it again.
Wait, they had their guns again!
No!
My bully!
I salute my father!
I almost got a strike!
I almost got a strike guys.
It was so close.
No you sh...
Guys, no no no.
I almost got a strike guys.
I almost did it.
You don't understand!
There you go.
That's different.
Oh shit!
No no no no no no no no no no!
Let me punch you!
There you go.
Alright, it's fine.
It's fine.
How do I activate...
Okay, I don't have double batter hands yet.
No!
Nope nope!
Yes!
No!
How did he get up so fast?
I don't understand!
No!
Joker, you ghoster!
Joker's ghosting!
Also isolated, thank you for the 10 conventions.
Thank you.
I can't believe he's a ghoster.
Fucking no integrity!
I can't believe my criminal doesn't have any integrity.
So fucked up.
Just gonna...
Nothing?
That's so fucked up.
No.
Okay.
No you didn't.
Get up.
There you go.
This is my stealth.
This is my stealth, guys.
No!
There you go.
Bye.
No!
Get over here.
That's fucking right.
They can't see me.
Get over here.
That's fucking right.
I told you I don't need stealth!
Boom!
Apparently I can cut them down too.
Guys, I learned something new.
I can cut him...
Ow.
Okay.
Alright.
Him falling on his head is not a bad thing.
Okay.
How do I get this guy?
Get over here.
Come on!
Come over here!
It's not...
Where is he?
Is he in front of me?
Oh he is.
I was like where is he?
See I told you guys I can do this.
Hell yeah!
First try!
First fucking try.
Let's go.
Let's see if I can get a chance.
Can I open the door now?
Am I missing anything here?
Whoops.
Oh.
A little me this?
Is this a little me this?
Well anyway as I was saying...
I never understood the...
I never understood...
that they do publicity stunts.
To like get attention...
regarding like ecological...
ecological...
ecological awareness.
Because it's like...
It just makes you look stupid.
Like yes you're getting attention.
But like you're just making people...
more spiteful.
And they're gonna be like you know what?
Fuck the...
It's just gonna make people be like fuck the environment.
Like even if you're trying to...
convince them to care about the environment.
People are just gonna be like...
No fuck the environment.
.
Remember the Waynes?
How could anyone forget?
Oh.
.
It just ends up making people like...
hate you more.
Oh hey remember Thomas Wayne and Martha Wayne?
Nice.
Look at that I can solve for this!
No Doki that's just you.
No it's not I don't...
I'm not gonna be fuck the environment.
But it makes people wanna be like...
fuck the environment because people would be like...
you're not so stupid.
.
Thomas Wayne was a gifted surgeon...
and heir to the Wayne fortune.
Dedicated to philanthropy as much as medicine.
He and his wife Martha...
were well known and respected in Gotham.
Martha Wayne shared...
her...
shared her husband Thomas'...
charitable nature and was dedicated to her son's...
upbringing.
She was well...
dedicated to her son...
she was well regarded in the Gotham City's social...
circles and helped host lavish...
charity bars at Wayne Manor.
Their tragic murder at the hands...
of the desperate burglar Joe Chill...
in Gotham's...
crime alley shook...
the city...
to its core and led to years...
of urban blight.
It also...
inspired their son...
Bruce to eventually become...
the Batman.
Oh wait, fun facts.
I forgot about...
what are the heights.
6 foot 1 and 5 foot 8.
Man...
even she's taller than the penguin.
Wait, she's so tall!
5 foot 8?
Does that count the heels?
You're so fucking...
tall!
Highly gifted and well trained surgeon...
heir to the Wayne, dedicated mother to...
Bruce Wayne, wife to Tom...
I like how like the attributes is like...
she's a mom, she's a wife.
.
Makes fun of crime alley when she goes...
when she goes to R.S.
Alley.
Thank you for the super chat...
Dr. Cranberry.
Thank you, thank you.
Is there anything here?
Oh wait, teeth.
Nice.
I got the teeth.
I know we're supposed to go here...
but maybe there's like bonus things here.
Just wanna make sure there's... Whoa!
Whoa!
.
This is perfect bullying!
Okay.
Okay, I can get a strike here.
.
It's perfect!
Wait, he got him so fast!
What the fuck?
That's bullshit!
Why did he get to get him so fast?
This is bullshit.
Not gonna lie.
.
Bro!
That's not fair!
.
Alright, nice.
Get out.
.
What the fuck?
You get to stop a take down?
That should be legal!
.
You okay?
I was like, wait, bro, are you okay?
Sorry about that.
I didn't mean to.
.
Nice.
Okay, nice.
That's a lot of XP too.
They're dead!
Oh wait, what the fuck?
Whoa!
.
I was like, they're dead!
Turns around the corner.
.
Sure.
Carl Todd.
Who are you?
.
You're a janitor?
Oh, you are!
.
Kara Todd next to the crowbar.
That's not gonna happen.
It's gonna explode.
Oh my god.
It's so difficult.
What?
Wait, there's more than one?
There you go.
Oh, there's three!
That's why!
That makes sense.
There you go.
Easy.
Nice!
I did it!
Maybe just leave.
Actually, no, they can't leave because it's an island.
I was wondering, where are the boats?
Sorry, he can't just leave.
Yeah, but like, Poison Ivy.
Why would you think it's the last place people will be?
It's literally Poison Ivy.
What the fuck?
Where are all these?
Are these things at the bottom?
Oh, it's the booby traps.
Okay.
What do I do?
Wait, can't I...
Can't you swim?
Yeah.
Yeah, can't you swim?
Can't this guy fucking swim?
There's no sharks in fucking Goth... actually, there might be.
Because there's like, what's his name?
King Shark?
Never mind.
There could be sharks because there's King Sharks.
I forgot.
In Gotham... Jesus Christ.
In Gotham City.
Hey!
All
those innocent citizens!
Alright, I'm just gonna... Sorry, Joker.
You were
a doc... She's still a doctor!
She doesn't lose her doctorate!
What?
She's had platinum, but doesn't mean she didn't go to college!
What do you mean she were a doctor?
Did she lose her license?
Oh, she could have lost her license.
I forgot.
That can happen.
I forgot that can happen.
I forgot.
They could have possibly revoked her PhD from killing people.
You're right.
You're right!
Alright, then this one in the next room.
I can't believe it!
She lost her license!
I can't believe murder can make you lose your license!
That's a bit unfair!
You're right!
You can't revoke a PhD!
I can't believe I'm telling you when I visit.
I get so lonely on my own.
You don't want me to be lonely.
Just don't let me know.
Steven!
No.
You can trust me, Steven.
You beat her!
Now give me a kiss.
I can't.
He has a wife!
What's wrong with you?
Don't you love me?
You simp!
Call me Ivy.
Of course!
I love you.
Oh my god!
Homewrecker!
Oh, yeah!
How could she lose her fucking PhD?
She's still a doctor!
She's still Dr. Ivy.
All these doctors have that I can fix them attitude.
Barley, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We're all Steven's gator.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You guys won't leave me for Ivy, right?
Wow, Mad Hatter!
Okay, which one's the Mad Hatter?
Oh, there it is.
Is that the Mad Hatter?
No, that's not.
Guys.
Guys, I'm serious guys.
What does Ivy have that I can't provide?
I can provide entertainment.
LOL LOL LOL Would she play Batman Arkham Asylum?
Adam?
What's my PhD?
Okay, look.
She can't even practice her fucking doctorate!
Her PhD is useless!
Also, where the fuck is the Mad Hatter puzzle?
She can't, just not legally.
Oh, so now she's not... she was never a real doctor anyway!
It's a PhD!
It's not even a medical doctor!
It's just professors!
It's just a PhD professor!
She writes research papers, not fucking cures cancer!
Okay, but like, you know... oh, there it is.
But like, I'm not trying to say professors do not deserve to be called doctors.
I just want you guys to know that.
I'm just saying that like, you guys are saying she's a medical doctor, but she is not a medical doctor.
She is a theoretical doctor.
Several people are typing.
Obsessed from a young age with Lewis Carroll's book of Alice Adventures in Wonderland, Jarvis is...
Jarvis Tech, an expert hypnotist, embraced the delusion that he was the incarnation of a character in the story, the Mad Hatter.
Using his skills for mesmerism, the Mad Hatter has committed many crimes, often themed around the book that inspired him and his love of hats and headgear.
Oh my god, he plays Team Fortress 2!
Doing so far as to implant his hats with mind-controlled chips to amplify his hypnosis skills.
Above all other headwear, however, he covets Batman's distinctive cowl and will stop at no- Just fucking hire a cosplayer!
Make it- Oh yeah, it's a collector's item.
Oh, he wants especially one of a kind items.
Alright, where do I go?
It's this way.
He wants the real thing.
He wants the one of a kind collecti- Okay, but like...
Batman does not have one Batsuit.
That's all I'm gonna say.
There's no way he has one Batsuit.
Just give- Just give him the cowl to stop so he can stop- He's also schizophrenic?
They're all schizophrenic!
There's a pattern, Batman!
Oh shit.
At this rate, you'll never catch me!
AHHHH!
Batman, if the- If the majority of the villain is schizophrenic, maybe the issue is the schizophrenia that's running around fucking Gotham City!
He's also schizophrenic!
I swear, 80% of these villains are just schizophrenic!
Look!
Delusion schizophrenic!
There must be some- You know what?
It might be the water, honestly.
I feel like this is- There's something wrong with the gene pool in Gotham City.
Like, it's like Australia, where like all the criminals got like- Got like deported to Australia a long time ago.
Like, I feel like at this point, there's- There's- There has to be a pattern.
Like, there's something has to be in the water!
Or like, medical history, there's something wrong!
Batman!
Please!
Fund the medical facilities in Gotham City, Batman!
That's all we need!
We can fix it so easily!
It's always the water.
Oh no.
Oh hey, we're gonna need this.
Why is there mushrooms here?
Oh.
Here we go.
Nice.
Can't believe you blame my felonies on my genetics!
It's like the murder genes!
Whoops, sorry.
It's like the murder genes from Riverdale!
I'll make sure there's- Oh, it's so nice that the mod gets rid of the flashbang.
It's actually so nice.
It's so fucking nice, man.
Holy shit.
The shadows can only be seen by those with a different view of life.
What the fuck does that mean?
What?
What the fuck is that?
Joker?
Ooh.
I don't like this.
I don't like this, Joker!
Where the fuck do I get out of here?
Oh, this way.
Wheeee!
I missed the scan in the vent?
It's alright.
I cannot deal with mazes.
A rat catcher needs more than just his charm to lead.
Oh, it's the Pied Piper!
I need to scan some rats?
Where are the rats?
Oof.
Help me!
What the fuck is that?
Oh.
Please.
Stop.
I told you what you wanted to know.
You got everyone.
Pulling time.
Please.
You can let me go.
Hey, you promise you won't tell anyone about Joker's plan?
Well, okay then.
Help this guy to his feet.
Then shoot him in the face!
Why do we always go back to Riverdale, Doki?
Thank you for the super chat, Alan.
Thank you, thank you.
Did you think we'd just let you walk out of here?
He doesn't even have guns.
How do you do shoot?
It's funny.
Listen up.
I'm gonna kick you a bit more.
Then when you pass out, I'll drag you back in there and throw you down the hall.
Let all your friends watch.
Yeah.
I could stop this at...
Oh!
I could have stopped this at any time, but I had to stay there for lore.
How fucked up are you, Doki?
I'm sorry!
I could have saved you earlier, but the lore was more important.
I'm sorry.
I hate it when they interrupt my fucking finishers.
I'm so sorry, man.
The lore was just too good.
Hey, are you okay?
Sorry for giving you extra trauma.
Are you okay?
Do I look okay?
They were gonna kill me.
We were in the...
Yeah, I just got there.
Sorry.
And they came in with jokers shooting up the place.
I literally just got there.
And they left us in the cages.
I was not watching, I swear to God.
Rescue orderlies held hostage in the aviary.
In the aviary?
Where am I?
There's so many objectives!
Oh my god, there's so many things to do.
Why can't you do this?
Okay.
Oh hey, really?
Let me do this.
Oh, I don't have that thing again.
Uh... is it this way?
Yeah, that should be it.
Where are the fucking rats?
She's using her womanly charms against him.
Ducky, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Clearly those grunts don't know the epic high and lows of high school!
I fucking love that quote.
Nice.
Is this a tribute to... oh wait, Constantine?
Oh, Constance.
Okay, never mind.
There's no claws in the guard so someone's using the roof instead.
Is that one of the orderlies?
Wait, how did they get them in there?
The bat is on the way.
If you see him, send the annoying doctors to help.
Yeah!
They're going down!
Oh.
If I hear what?!
If I hear what, Joker?!
What am I going to hear?!
Joker!
If I hear what?!
I'll never know!
I'll never know, guys!
Oh my god, I was too slow!
I'll never know what I'm going to hear!
My god.
I can't believe it.
That was too slow.
Please.
Did it crash again?
Like, what?!
Oh my god, it crashed again!
Nooooo!
Give me a second.
It crashed again.
Let me...
Yeah.
Play.
Next time, man.
To be fair, like, this PC has been like... it's just been like Frankenstein.
For...
So maybe there has always been that one part that's fucking up my PC.
But I'll never know!
Played it recently in Mod 3 and it still crashes.
It's not me!
It's just that...
Okay, games that are like...
Uh...
Games that are not compatible with new stuff, to be fair.
Because like, you know...
Like...
They're not compatible in terms of like... the more... the more new it is.
Like the graphics cards are not compatible with the old shit in games.
Alright.
Y'all finally...
I finally know!
Listen.
The bat is on the way.
If you see him, send the annoying doctors to...
Yeah, the optimization.
That's the down one, right?
Yeah!
They're going down!
Joker's men are all wearing the security colors.
I'll need to take out the operator first.
Uh...
No, is this stealth?
No...
Is this stealth?
Nooooo!
Okay.
Okay, I have the sonic batteram.
There you go.
Look over... What?
No!
It could be anybody's batteram!
It could be anybody's!
Why would it be me?
Guys!
It could be anybody!
I don't under... How did he know?
How did he know?
He's just a man wearing the security colors.
I'll need to take out the operator first.
It could be Robin's!
Like...
How did he know it's mine?
I don't understand.
It literally could have been anybody's.
That's all I'm gonna say.
Who else?
I don't know!
Other bat enthusiasts!
Why did Junker crash the game?
Is he stupid?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It could have been a Batman fan!
You know?
Okay.
Alright.
It's capitalism.
Someone... They must have sold, like, bootleg Batman batterams.
Alright?
Like, someone has merchandised Batman.
I bet you Bruce Wayne has, like, trademarked Batman.
There's no fucking way batterams are not, like, a trademark item where people fucking sell it.
There's no fucking way.
No.
I don't know how that worked, but okay.
Yes, but no!
There's no fucking way!
He does not have Batman trademarked.
Pretend this is a metal kit.
Right?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
There has to be Batman merch!
It's fucking capitalism!
Why would they not fucking capitalize on Batman?
I bet you Batman is somebody's Oshii!
Wait,
how the fuck do I do this?
Can I kill him?
Okay.
No!
I can't believe it!
I'm so close!
How?!
Oh my god, how?!
I'm so fucking sad.
I'm so sad.
I was doing so well!
He saw my hands!
I don't understand!
Kaz, Bruce Wayne having Batman trademarked would be a little bit sussy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's why he has so many Robins!
Exactly!
Limited edition new Robin merch!
Oh my god.
Bro, it makes so much more sense!
I am Kaz.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It makes sense!
Robin!
New Robin debut!
Oh my god!
Robin debut!
Help me!
Someone!
Get me out of this thing!
Yeah.
Okay, Jason was not making enough money.
So they had to graduate him.
But then it was a publicity stunt.
So it boosted Jason's number.
It boosted Jason's number.
By gra- And then like they brought him back.
They ungraduated him.
It's so smart!
Bruce is so fucking smart!
Oh my god!
This is how he became a billionaire!
This is exactly how merchandising...
Merchandising...
Batman merchandising is the most lucrative like...
It's the most lucrative way to earn money from him.
Wait, scan the guy on the wall.
There's a guy?
Yeah, but tech is like a side thing.
It's the side gear.
Oh, this guy?
Killer Mo- That's the Killer Moth?
Walker was a minor criminal who adopted the identity of Cameron Van Cleer.
A bastard criminal who in turn masqueraded as the costumed super villain Killer Moth.
He is a hired gun for Gotham City.
Oh my god.
That looks fucking stupid.
But he's- And he used a weapon including his Cancun gun.
Does not protect him from regular defeat at the hands of Batman.
Who the fuck would hire this guy?
With the fame and identity chance.
Skilled inventor.
Immoral and motivated by feelings of insecurity.
Oh shit, I'm sorry.
I didn't mean that.
I'm sorry man.
I'm sorry bro.
I was- No, no, please.
I don't want to fuck it up again.
Okay, I can do this.
I can do this guys.
You mad here Mothman!
You mad here!
Why did I fucking- Who told me to do the takedown?
Alright, I listened to the one guy that was like, you should do the takedown.
And I was like, I should do the takedown.
I'm one!
Get me out of here!
God damn it.
I need to take out the operator first.
I got one guy.
It was me!
Fuck you!
I saw someone that was like, do the silent takedown.
It'll be so funny.
I was like, whoa, really?
Would it actually be that funny?
Alright.
How the fuck?
Please get me out of here.
Please.
It was me, Barry!
God, just let these janitors die!
I don't care anymore!
Bab I should get two!
Chica should get at least two!
All I'm saying is that I should get at least two.
Okay, I'm gonna run.
Alright.
Wait, do I have to scan it again?
Do I have to scan this fucker again?
I'll scan him later when I kill them all!
I'm gonna do that little thing I did earlier.
There we go.
I did it.
I fucking did it.
Take down the henchmen.
What?
Take down?
Oh, I did it.
I did it.
Now pull the lever, you're right.
First try!
Okay.
Now I can scan him.
But is that what they want?
They get to be strong.
I'm gonna try to get him.
Okay.
Oh, hey.
Hey there.
I didn't even see you.
Alright, where's the... where is he?
Let me scan him again.
Let me scan him first!
Don't come over!
Oh shit, okay!
Get over here.
Oh wait, that's the last guy.
Oh!
Fuck!
Nice.
I did it.
Bro, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I feel like Jason graduated being big in the Indies.
But I'm loving the stream, Doki.
Yeah, but he crawled back to Batman.
Alright,
cut it over here.
I saved your life, we're gonna say.
Say thank you!
I had no idea Joker was involved until he burst in the lab.
Where is the lab?
Back over there.
I always get buzzed through.
There's a hidden door, but... well, you know, it's hidden.
I'll find it.
Stay here.
Alright, let's go.
Wait, yes!
He does have a wife!
He does have a wife.
All the robins eventually come back.
The merchandising is just too good.
The branding.
It's almost like Nightwing...
Nightwing had a good...
Nightwing becomes Batman later!
He's part of the problem.
He doesn't have a solo career because he ends up becoming Batman.
It's all connected.
There we go.
Did I go the other way?
Oh yeah, I guess so.
Right?
The other door, right?
Batman is just too good of a branding!
The capitalism is just too good!
Just think about the merchandising!
Getting Termina?
Oh, don't leave?
Okay.
Don't say that about my Oshii!
Where's the hidden terminal?
Where?
Oh, there it is!
I see it!
Please.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
I'm good.
Sorry, I sort of ran...
Sorry.
The wall...
There's a vent over there.
How do I get to that vent?
Oh, it's this way.
Okay.
Oh, there it is!
Oh, I can open it.
I was gonna say I should use my backlaw or not.
I bet you Superman isn't even a farmer's boy.
It's just all PR.
I bet you Clark Kent isn't a farm boy!
What the fuck is that?
Oh, no!
Don't say that!
You can't do that!
Wait, what?
I'm just back here.
Wait, I could've done that.
I could've just done this?!
Wait, this... this was... actually, no.
This was more complicated.
This was actually more complicated, not gonna lie.
Where the fuck is this statue?
Follow the fingerprints.
Okay.
Let me find the fingerprints.
That was the intended way.
I made it much more difficult.
I ran past the secret tunnel.
Look, I fucking gained so hard.
Like, come on.
What I did was cooler.
I'm not gonna lie.
I could've went up!
Oh my god, I could've went so many different other ways.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Time to do the Joker gas.
Yay!
There we go.
Where's that?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, thank god it's next to me, because I would never find it.
Thank fucking god.
Joker!
He's gonna do it!
They're gonna go Bane!
He's Bane-ing out!
Never go full Bane.
Oh, oh!
Oh god!
Oh!
Ugh!
I like how his- their pants are okay.
Oh fuck!
I forgot!
Wow!
What the fuck!
I can't- I got charged at!
Okay, that's bullshit.
That is so bullshit.
Alright.
Oh shit.
Oh fuck!
What is he doing?
Ow.
That is okay!
That is actually bullshit though.
That is actually bullshit.
Alright, here we go.
There's two.
How the fuck- no!
This is much worse!
No!
Okay.
There we go.
I can hit both of them at the same time.
Okay.
There we go.
That's fucking right.
No!
He's a- I need to get this guy too!
What do I do?
Oh!
I just didn't hit him!
Okay!
I'm just like, what do I do?
Get him too!
That's right!
Stop hitting yourself!
Are you guys stupid?
Oh shit.
I didn't mean that.
I'm so sorry.
I did not mean that.
Oh!
Oh my god, they're picking up people.
Oh fuck!
Okay.
Okay, I need to get out of there.
Get on!
Piggyback time!
It's piggyback time!
Get over here!
We gotta hit each other!
It's the only way!
They're tossing people!
That's illegal!
Why are they tossing people?
Why can't I toss people?
I should be strong enough!
Guys...
Holy f- I like how he can hit his teammates too with that.
That's actually pretty funny.
Hehehehehe.
Charge meeeeee!
What?
You're too far!
Can you get closer?
Nice.
Alright.
Charge, charge, charge, charge!
Nice.
Wait, did he...
Is he gonna die now?
Okay.
Almost there.
Oh fuck!
Oh nice, I dodged.
Fucking dodged.
Oh!
Nice.
Okay.
One down.
Wait, can I just like... poke him and he'll die?
Oh nice.
Yeah, I can.
Please.
Please let me pick you up!
You wouldn't let me pick him up!
Easy.
Alright, let's go this way.
Wait, what?
Need tool coming up?
It's time!
It's time for that one...
Oh wait, upgrade time!
Upgrade time.
Which... what upgrade do we get?
That's why Ivy's gonna help us.
She loves plants.
I'm pretty sure the plants are getting tortured right now, making that venom.
What do we get?
Health?
Armor?
Okay, armor.
Nice.
Don't worry, Ivy!
We're gonna commit... ecoterrorism?
I don't know if that is considered ecoterrorism.
I don't even...
No, because we're saving...
We're saving the plants!
No, no, we're good people.
Yes, we're good people.
We're good people this time.
Where the fuck is the terminal?
Oh, there it is.
How do I...
How do I do this?
Where the fuck... oh, there it is.
How?
Batman?
What did I do?
Oh, my ship!
The Bat Ship!
Why didn't you give me this earlier?
Did I just pick this up?
The Line Launcher.
That's right!
I can go back and do all the stuff that needs this!
But I won't.
Yay!
Now I can go find Ivy.
Where is Ivy?
Locate Poison Ivy using the Thermo Trail.
Yeah, where is it?
At 25... 4%.
I guess like... oh, the closer I get, the higher percentage.
You're all dead.
Joker was busy while I fought his monsters.
He'll pay for this.
Let's back this way.
I guess I can get that one Riddler Trophy.
I'll give you guys a one.
I'll give you guys like a plus one.
Don't worry.
Where is it?
Here?
It's here!
Guys, see?
I'm a good person.
I gave you guys that one.
Only because I have to go here anyway.
The only reason is because I have to be here.
Poison Ivy!
We're here to save your plants!
I'm here now, my poor darling.
Yes, I know he's found us.
But I won't let him hurt you.
I'll kill him first.
I know Dr. Young mutated these plants to produce venom.
Yes, and I heard it through the grapevine the evil woman paid the price.
I need you to help me create an antidote.
Why should I?
Let Joker have his fun.
I'll enjoy watching you squirm.
I'll be back.
Are you still wearing a shirt?
I mean as if like why is she wearing her like green outfit?
This is lower reason.
I mean her fucking plant outfit!
I'll be after you next.
And I'll be waiting.
Is that it?
That's just her interaction?
She's just gonna give me like exposition?
We're not gonna do anything?
We're not gonna fight her?
She's like so important.
I need to find a way into Killer Croc's lair.
It's somewhere below Arkham Island.
There's nothing on the system about where he's kept.
I found a door near the Batcave but it's shut tight.
There's got to be another way in.
I left guard Cash in the mansion.
I'll see if he can shed some light on where Croc's kept.
Asalondis, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
Saves the bird.
Just let the innocent people die.
Okay, look.
Sometime...
Wait, what the fuck?
We don't have guns though.
Can I just do this?
Alright, who's next?
Who's next?
Come on!
You can't dodge this forever!
That's right!
Alright, get over here.
Nice.
Alright.
You know what?
By the way, the eighth guy...
Look, they lined up too!
They're like, me, my turn, my turn!
And they're like, it's my turn!
Alright, next is your turn.
Get over here.
Last guy!
Come on, you can't dodge this forever!
Watch out, hold on.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Mommy.
Look at that.
It's that easy.
Whoop!
She's coming.
They didn't put their stats on intellect, that's for sure.
Alright, we gotta collect plant spores from Killer Croc's lair.
Talk to... where the fuck is that?
Is that outside of Gotham?
Oh it is, it's at the Gotham Mansion.
Alright, how do I get out of here?
I don't remember.
This way?
Yes, this way.
Nice, it was that easy.
Where are the rats?
Oh, I solved it.
Humpty Dumpty?
Wait, I didn't know there's a Humpty Dumpty.
An obese bald man named Humpty Dumpty is for his egg-like form.
Humpty Dum...
Humphrey Dumpler is obsessed... okay, now that's just his parents being cruel.
Like, this is just his parents' fault.
Humphrey Dumpler is obsessed with taking things apart and putting them back together.
His crimes at first were minor break-ins leading to small...
What the fuck you want?
The fuck's that fat Mario?
Holy shit, bro!
His name is already Humphrey Dumpler!
You don't have to do that to him!
You set up for failure, yeah!
Functioning due to Dumpler's inability adequately resemble...
...reassemble them after taking them apart.
But soon his obsession grew to the point that major disasters occurred in Gotham.
And Dumpler's crimes also extended into a gruesome attempt to fix his abusive grandmother by disemowing...
Wow!
And then attempting a Frankenstein-like reassembly.
How come he is a model inmate?
His quiet nature imposing physique...
...fearing him to the madness surrounding him.
Jesus, he just wants to fucking take things apart.
That's all he wants to do.
What did he fucking do?
Debut 2003.
...
Ritualized child...
Dude this...
...
Bro, this person just had a really fucking hard life.
His parents named him Humphrey Dumpler!
...
Bro, it's not his fault.
Parents literally named him Humphrey Dumpler.
...
Alright, we gotta go...
We gotta go into the vent apparently.
...
...Vent time.
We gotta find some rats.
...
We're the rat catcher.
No rats here!
...
Where the fucking rats?
Oh my god, there's no rats anywhere.
...
Look down in vent?
There's another vent?
...
Where?
It's a sewer.
No rats in here.
...
Scan the broken vent?
Is that where the rat is?
...
Liars?
This vent in front of me?
...
Is that a vent?
Alright, we'll never figure this out.
I gave up already.
...
I gave up.
We'll never figure it out.
...
Let's see, we'll just go back downstairs.
And then...
Wait, there's a person there.
Bro, I'm not even thinking about you right now, really?
...
I wanna kill this one guy that's underneath.
The rats, what?
...
Wait, this is a...
This is a sewer.
I should be coming here.
...
Oh dang, I found the trophy!
Nice.
Okay, now I don't even remember how to get out of here.
...
This way?
No.
Where am I?
...
Oh no.
Okay, I thought like it's the cliff is just gonna start.
I literally thought like it's just gonna fall on me.
I was like, oh fuck, I might have fucked up.
...
Alright.
Where the fuck?
Where?
Where am I?
...
Where the fuck am I?
Where's the exit?
...
Guys!
Okay, now that's the entrance.
The exit's like here.
Okay, I need to jump here.
... This must be the exit.
Right?
Yeah, okay here.
Not lost.
Not lost, guys, I figured it out.
... Where am I?
...
Hello?
Can I go back up?
...
No!
Okay.
Yeah, I can't do this.
Here?
Okay.
And then...
No!
Oh, here.
Oh, I figured it out!
Yay!
Oh, it's the rat again!
Wait, no, I didn't figure it out.
Well, yeah, I figured it out!
Okay, we need to find the rat.
The rat's up here!
Rats, rats, rats.
Rats.
Where the fuck is the rats?
It's in this vent somewhere.
Look down?
Where do I look down?
Here!
Oh, there it is!
We did it, we beat the rats.
Once employed as an actual rat captain...
...in Gotham, Otis Flemingen soon started using his natural gift and affinity with an ability to control rats to stage a variety of crimes.
Eventually, his control over the vermin grew until he threatened Gotham City with a variable army of rodents.
Incarcerated many times at Blackgate, he is able to do as much damage within prisons without using his loyal pets to relay messages and transport materials outside the maze of ventilation ducts.
...and he is able to control rats that wind through the giant prison...
Wait, how tall is he though?
I put 11.
...and he lives in the sewer.
Poor guy.
Alright you guys get to look at him.
I'm going to use a bat to your very back.
Back it for buddy!
Alright, let's beat them up.
Alright.
Oh, he's so trapped.
Oh no, I'm so trapped.
Oh no!
Get over here.
Oh no, I'm so trapped.
Get up!
Get up, bitch!
Come on!
Oh no, I'm so trapped!
Wait, how does he... Come on, I need to pull you in.
I will pull you into the water if it's the last thing I do!
Whoops, sorry, I couldn't aim.
Come on, you can't stay up there forever!
Oh my god, they actually programmed it so I can't electrocute them.
That's so fucked up.
That's actually so fucked up.
I guess I'll do this then.
I guess I'll do it the hard way.
I guess I'll do it this way.
Do you guys know they're planning on rebooting DC Comics again?
I don't even know how...
How many times they rebooted the fucking DC lore.
Again?
Yeah, again.
Alright, goodbye.
How many times have they rebooted DC Universe anyway?
Alright, let's see.
He's on top!
No!
No I'm not!
No, I'm rude!
We know he is.
No, I'm not!
I just got you a gift up there!
Wait, what did my sonic thing go?
You just shut that thing off.
I was going to say, where did it go?
No!
Come on, Libby!
Get down!
Yes, there you go.
Silent takedown.
Take that off me!
It's been rebooted five times?!
I think that's one of the biggest issues.
One of the biggest issues.
It's just rebooted so many times that you don't know which is the real...
It gets boring because it's like... How many times are we going to watch Batman's parents die?
Like at that rate.
How many times do we watch his parents die?
Goodbye.
New new new new new new 52.
I swear to God.
If this one guy ruins it all...
They better not wreck on Batman's underwear.
I swear.
If they take away his underwear, I'm out.
You didn't do anything.
You didn't even do anything either.
You can't blame that on me.
What the fuck?
Wait, what?
I thought you were against this, Ivy.
I was hoping for a 40 foot killer plan, but you don't always get what you want, do you?
Oh shit, is she beefed up now?
Is she going to be a Dommy Mommy now?
It's like those like... You know like those like bodybuilders?
Oh my gosh, the women bodybuilder competitions go so fucking hard.
Oh my God.
She's going to be like those women bodybuilders.
What do I go?
Collect plants.
How do I get out of here then?
What do I do?
Can I just cut it with my batter hand?
Maybe my fist can cut it.
What the fuck?
Where do I go then?
Do I go back?
Drop down?
There's a down?
Oh, there's a down.
Sorry, I forgot we're down.
Down is...
Alright, nice.
Go up.
This way.
Bro, I swear.
If she is not...
If she is not swole as fuck like the women bodybuilder competition, then they...
Then they've missed a point.
They've missed a mark.
If she's not extra hot, I'm done.
Oh no!
Wait, are they... Oh no, did they kill them?
Oh, thank God.
Okay, I was going to say.
I thought they were going to make them swole.
That is...
Can I just hit it?
Why can't I make a flame... bat a flame thrower?
A bat flame thrower.
I should be able to make a ba... Ow.
Oh, it doesn't hurt that much.
What the fuck?
How the fuck did these guys die?
I should be allowed to make a bat flame thrower.
Oh, I can punch it?
Okay, let me punch him first.
Okay.
Oh.
Okay, I'll...
I love how I can just punch the flat...
Just punch the plat, Batman!
Wait, I'll give his XP!
I'm going to punch all the plants.
I guess...
Fuck the environment, but in-game.
There we go.
Oh my God, they... Oh, it's just 25 XP.
It's not that much actually.
Fist the... No!
Batman just fist the plant.
Batman.
Why so serious, Batman?
Just fist the plant.
Oh, yeah.
But it adds up, Doki!
No, I feel like this is just some fucking... somebody's sick fetish right now.
Oh, shit.
Alright.
Look how it... It kills him.
Let's see.
You know what I realized?
I found out that before, like, Disney...
bought Marvel and made all the fucking Disney movies.
Okay, I have to go this way, right?
The only popular characters in Marvel was like Spider-Man and...
was just Spider-Man and the X-Men and Wolver... I mean, Wolverine is practically a fucking X-Men.
And like DC basically had the fucking...
monopoly really for DC hero... for the hero market.
And now everything has to be a fucking...
M...
What is it?
Has to be like a...
a uni...
What's the word?
A cinematic universe?
Everything has to be a goddamn cinematic universe.
I'm so tired of cinematic universe.
Just let it end.
Let it end!
I feel like...
downstairs is poison.
Woop.
Whoops.
I'm tired of MCU's!
I'm tired of cinematic universes!
Versus...
Let things end!
Who gives a fuck about nostalgia?
I don't care!
How do I go?
Oh, back here.
Okay.
How do I go there?
Can I climb on the TV?
Weeeeee!
Guys, I can't climb on TVs.
Oh wait, I'm up here now.
How did I get up here?
Where am I?
What do I do?
Oh.
Balcony.
Okay.
I looked around.
Alright.
Question mark.
Maybe here?
I head across here?
No, that's a podium.
God damn it, that's a podium!
That's a fucking podium!
Where do I drop?
Oh, I can drop here.
Alright, nice.
Can I punch?
Can I fist this plat?
No, wait.
Oh, this way!
Okay.
Go up here.
I'm tired of nostalgia bait.
It's so stupid.
Did you guys know they released new Star Wars stuff again?
I'm so tired.
Please.
Where do I go?
Here?
I guess so.
I've lost track of how many fucking...
Uh...
What the fuck?
I lost track of how many fucking Star Wars shit they've made already.
Maybe here?
Yeah, I was like looking at Disney...
Please!
Out of fuck... Okay, nice.
That counts.
Okay, that counts.
I take this.
Uh...
This way?
That counts.
No!
Let me exploit!
Oh, hey.
Let me exploit it.
Oh, nice.
That works.
Yeah!
That's nice.
Oh, hey guys.
Hi there.
I'm so glad you're here.
What's the deal with the plants?
It's complicated.
Let me guess.
Poison Ivy.
She teamed up with Joker.
All that matters...
I have no idea how to do this legit.
I'm glad that I've exploited my way into this.
There's always a but, isn't there?
Where do you keep Killer Croc?
I found a door in the sewers, but it's sealed shut.
That monster's got his own special cell.
It's right below the transfer room, back in Intensive Treatment.
Elevator goes right down to an old sewer.
He just dropped meat down there every day or so.
And tried to forget about it.
It's locked off.
More security than the Joker.
You won't get in without the Warden's permission.
He has the codes.
I have the codes.
Thanks, Cash.
Stay here and do not go near the plants.
How do you, like, not go near?
They're literally everywhere!
I like how someone was saying, like, oh, their companies are too scared to do anything but nostalgia bait because they don't want to make anything new.
They're too scared of spending money that they're losing money!
That's so stupid!
Okay, I gain access to Killer Croc's lair via Intensive Treatment.
I have to get out of here?
Goddamnit.
Okay, I need to figure out how to get out of here.
It's so dumb!
Because they're too scared of spending money on experimenting...
I think that they end up making it worse.
So like, what's the point?
How do I get out of here now?
I've already exploded my way to here, but now I don't know how to get there.
I guess like...
This way?
I'm lost.
Whoops.
Yeah!
Yes!
That's what I like!
I did it!
I figured it out!
The cheese!
Cheesed my way out and that's how I like it.
Alright, grapple here.
Nice!
That was just that easy.
Like I said, this island has been well and truly buried.
Oh well.
We have to go over here.
I guess I can go from the right side?
I'll go right side.
Weee!
Any more plants?
I would like the back treatment.
50% off!
Here I go!
Oh!
This one plant.
You thought you could get away.
Boop!
Nice!
Tell your friends.
Alright, we gotta fist this one too.
Boop!
Nice!
Alright.
Sit this way.
Okay, here.
Am I even at 50% of this game?
What the fuck?
Why are they wearing jackets now?
See?
I told... See?
The Joker's great!
Their men was cold and the Joker gave them jackets.
Guys, look at that.
Now it's bowling time.
Bowling!
Nice.
Three.
I take this.
Look at that!
Joker is so considerate, guys.
They literally gave them jackets because he doesn't want them to be cold.
Your boss would never.
He's so nice.
I know, right?
He's so nice!
That's fucking right.
I gotta make sure like...
Oh nice, I took his...
I took his fucking taser all the way.
Oh, I wanted to use the weapon for that one time, but not the other time.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Counter that.
Where can I throw my batterams?
Wait, how did he pick that up?
Alright, nope.
That's fucking right.
Counter.
How did I counter that?
No!
Oh shit.
No, no, no, no.
Fucking right.
No, no, no, no, no, no!
Get away from me!
Okay.
Now I'm just gonna go... boop.
Boop.
He can die eventually, right?
That's right.
He'll die eventually.
There's no way you can live through all these batterams.
Simple physics!
Okay, now I'm just gonna...
Now you're just pissing me off.
Hahaha!
Okay.
You've lived long enough.
Now I see it.
Now you don't.
There was a sniper up on the roof.
He got there somehow.
I'll find a way.
Wait, where's the sniper?
This guy?
Oh, that guy is the sniper.
Okay.
I mean, I can literally just go...
I can just climb.
Batman!
Climb!
I can't just climb.
Alright.
That's not fair.
Hahaha!
Alright.
I thought I could just climb.
I don't understand.
You mean I can't just climb everything?
Who would have thought?
I can't just climb everything.
Goodbye.
Not a spy there.
Bwee!
No!
Oh, wait.
I can't just get up there?
What if I align this?
There must be an exploit.
Oh, he sees me.
No, he doesn't.
Okay.
There must be an...
There's always an exploit.
God damn it.
I'm gonna go to the bathroom.
How the fuck do I get across?
Go up the tower?
This tower?
Okay.
This must be the tower.
Eww.
Okay.
Oh, there it is!
I knew it.
There's always an exploit.
Hello?
Hahaha!
How did you not see that?
Holy shit!
Joker, you need to invest in better...
better goons.
They're not gonna lie.
I love 2010 NPCs.
It made me feel so smart.
It's dark out.
Then don't be a fucking sniper!
Oh, shit.
Structural integrity.
I'm seeing seismic activity, okay?
Ivy's plants are taking hold.
I've got to stop them before the entire island is under her control.
If she is not swole as fuck, then this game's a 9 out of 10.
No swole Ivy.
It doesn't make sense.
Why is she not swole but the goons are?
I don't understand.
Hey, what's over here?
Oh, no.
Am I gonna be lost?
Am I gonna be lost again?
I think I'm gonna be lost again.
Okay, I need to go here.
Oh my god, I'm gonna be lost again.
If she is, I swear I'm gonna lose to Batman.
Plants can be swole?
What the fuck are you talking about?
They're thick plants.
Plants can be plump?
Okay, let's see.
I need to figure out how to do this.
Oh my god, this is a giant ass fucking vent.
Boop.
Okay, this way.
Yeah, have you seen peaches?
Are they ready?
I haven't used those yet.
Razor's just finishing his off now.
Good.
Let's test him out.
No, no, I'm still up.
Whoa.
Don't worry, I'm pretty sure Joker has Joker insurance.
Right?
Alright.
Boop.
Wait, no more inverted takedowns?
Wait, did he... did he fucked up all the Gorgons?
Ow.
Nope, nope.
There's no way he exploded this one, right?
He exploded this one.
There's no...
Whoa, he doesn't know.
He doesn't know.
There's no way they saw me, guys.
Watch this.
Bowling time.
Boop.
Two.
Okay, there you go.
There's no way they saw me here.
What the fuck?
I'm in the corner!
This is...
This is fucking legal!
I'm...
Who shot me?
Oh, my God!
Oh, dude, no!
I can't believe it!
I can't believe they saw me!
Okay.
Okay, this time I got this.
I can do this.
I'm... I can do this this time.
I don't need no gargoyle!
I don't need no gargoyles!
The gargoyles are not a crutch for me!
It's not a crutch, I swear!
I can't believe they're learning.
I can't believe the AIs are learning.
This isn't fair!
How do you afford all these guns?
Alright, yeah.
God damn it.
Now I actually have to stealth.
Can I just like keep killing them here?
Or do I just stay in the vent?
It's not a crutch!
I swear!
Okay.
Wait.
I'll just have them all over here.
And I'll beat them up.
It's okay.
They'll have to turn around.
someday, right?
Not everybody is totally better than my actual employer.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's okay.
They have to turn around soon, right?
Come on.
Turn around.
Ba da da da da da da da da Ba ba ba.
Alright.
That's fine.
It's fine.
As long as Joker doesn't ghost me again, we're fine.
He doesn't do any ghosting.
Oh my god.
Look at them.
They're back to back.
They covered his back.
What are these AIs?
He's so smart.
He doesn't see me, right?
Oh no.
He definitely doesn't see me.
Alright.
Come on.
Come up.
That's fucking right.
Go closer to your friend.
Oh fuck.
No.
That's not cool.
That's not fair.
Why are you over here?
Oh.
Okay.
Woo!
Wheeeee.
Back up, Bako.
It's not a crutch.
I swear.
The gargoyles are not a crutch.
I swear to god.
Okay.
Alright.
We can do this.
Oh.
I have an idea.
Okay.
I'm gonna tag this.
I have an idea.
Guys.
I figured it out.
I'm gonna set up a trap.
Okay.
And then...
Wait.
I can't use this here.
I can't... I can't... Okay.
It's okay.
It's fine.
I can't... I just realized I cannot use the... use the explosives while in the vent.
But it's okay.
He walked into my trap.
He was alone.
There we go.
It's that easy.
My trap.
Being alone.
Hahaha.
Alright.
Don't worry.
He doesn't know.
There's no way he knows.
Hahaha.
There's no way.
There's no way they knew.
There's no way he knows.
You're alone.
I'm coming for you.
You have no friends.
This is the perfect cover.
Oh shit.
Wait.
That's not great.
Nevermind.
He has friends now.
He has friends now guys.
That's not good.
Wait.
Is it bullying time?
It's bullying time.
Whoa!
No, no, don't turn back!
No, no, no!
Don't turn back!
Don't huddle up!
This is not Mungus!
Stop huddling!
It's not fun!
Oh hey, look at my legs though.
Holy shit, look at how thick my thighs are though.
Coker hired the finest goons with exactly 45 degrees of...
What?!
No!
Do not!
What did he... Why was he paranoid?!
No!
I can't believe you were paranoid!
We were so close!
I'm so sad.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
Why were you paranoid?
I don't understand!
Like, there was no reason to be paranoid!
All I'm saying was there was no reason for him to be that scared.
I'm just gonna kill this guy.
Okay.
We got this.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
This is it.
This is the try.
Shhhh.
This is it.
Okay.
Alright, I'm gonna start painting.
No...
No!
It's fine.
Not crutch!
It's fine!
Um...
It's fine.
It's so fine.
We're so fine.
Okay.
If I use...
If I use this Batarang...
Boom!
There we go.
He'll ruin everything!
And then...
And then I'll use this one.
Oops.
Alright.
I'm gonna make sure the other guy...
Come on.
One of you must be a loner.
One of you must not have friends.
Come on.
You can't all... Come on.
You can't all...
Be on good side together.
Okay.
Him.
That's looking great.
Okay.
See, I told you.
What do you mean this is painful to watch?
We're fucking gaming!
We're gaming right now!
Okay.
He's...
Is he a loner too?
What is this fucking buddy system shit right now?
Okay.
Who's not gonna head over there?
Alright.
What?
You're gonna head over there?
Okay.
You're gonna check each other out?
Oh, this guy.
He's not going to.
Okay.
Unless...
Oh my god.
Why are you doing checking that?
What are you doing?
All your friends are over there!
This guy's a loner, but I can't...
I can't fucking separate him from the rest.
Okay.
I'm gonna put this here.
No, I didn't.
Thank you, Super Chat!
Thank you!
Don't keep gaming.
I'm doing my best.
Okay.
Are you all just gonna be over there?
Holy shit.
They're huddled up together.
This is legal.
Alright.
Okay.
Whoops.
Oh my god.
He's so paranoid.
I'm gonna leave.
Why are they all grouped up?
Where are you?
Stop grouping up!
Fuck the buddy system!
It's not worth it!
Oh my god.
They're actually holding hands.
They're actually holding hands!
What the fuck is this bullshit?
Wait, they're actually...
This is stupid.
They're holding hands.
Come on.
No!
Woo woo woo woo woo woo woo!
No.
You can't come up here.
I'm fucking on the ceiling.
Look at them.
There's no way.
What do you mean how did I miss that?
How did I miss that?
Okay.
I got him up.
He's still not... Fuck he's still camping.
He's still fucking camping.
Okay.
Alright.
Come on.
Leave.
God.
They're so paranoid.
This one guy.
I'm just gonna bone rush him.
I'm just gonna fucking bone...
There's no way he can fucking kill me.
He's just one guy.
Alright.
This is it.
I can do this.
Watch.
I'm gonna bone rush him.
AHHHH!
Okay.
It worked.
I told you.
There's no way.
See?
Eventually they'll split up.
Please!
No!
I told you.
Eventually they'll split up.
There's no way.
I told you.
They'll split up eventually.
The buddy system will eventually fail.
There we go.
The buddy system will fail!
I'm coming with you.
I knew it.
I don't think I'm gonna bull this correctly.
That's fine.
No.
There we go.
They're lining up!
I hate this!
How the fuck did I miss that?
How?
I went between them!
How is that possible?
How can you go between them, Doki?
Oh my god.
They're leaving the buddy system.
This is it.
No.
No way.
This treatment belongs to us.
Okay.
They're leaving the buddy system.
I knew it!
The buddy system isn't forever!
Okay.
Alright.
We just gotta kill him.
This building is ours.
Joker said so.
Go!
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
This is it!
There's no way I can miss!
That's fucking right!
Bam!
There we go.
I did it.
That's how you do it.
That's how you stealth.
That's how you stealth, guys.
Any questions?
Any questions, guys?
I'm willing to... I'm here all day!
Alright, how the fuck do I unlock this?
It is inside...
The stealthiest bird out there.
Where the fuck is...
What's the code thing for this?
How the hell am I supposed to hack this?
What is this?
What the fuck is this?
Flawless execution.
Guys, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
No problem.
Oh, I could have done this and be like peek-a-boo!
What the fuck do I... Oh, it's over here.
Alright.
Joker gas time.
Let's see.
It should be here.
What?
Okay.
Oh, this...
Wait, there's a timer?!
Oh!
Sorry.
I didn't realize.
I actually didn't realize there's been a timer this entire time.
Alright.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Where the fuck is this one?
There.
Oh, this one's harder.
Oh no.
There we go.
Oh my god!
That one was so difficult, I couldn't find it!
It's okay, I did it.
First try.
First fucking try.
Can't believe there was a timer this entire time.
I was definitely not paying attention.
Thanks for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That was amazing.
See, and on the first try.
I know.
Oh my god.
How does she do it?!
How the fuck does she do it, guys?
Truly a gamer of her generation.
Basically this...
Hackers are getting a bit hard though.
Alright.
I'm gonna go in.
I had to make sure.
I had to make sure I was able to go in.
Wait, what's... what's this for?
There's nothing in here!
What's the point of hacking here if there's nothing here?
What the fuck?
I felt... I felt cheated out of this.
Oh my god.
I felt cheated out of this area.
Scan the picture?
Oh shit, was this a riddle?
Oh.
Okay.
I didn't realize there was a riddle here.
Riddle me this.
Okay, we gotta go this way.
Did anyone catch the game last night?
Huh?
Uhhhh.
What?
Huh?
What is it in the back car?
What?
Joker!
Oh my god, it's so cool!
Oh
my god, it's so cool!
I get to play Joker!
Oh my god, it's like...
Yeah, role reversal!
The asylum
was run by the criminals.
Just got to check your prisoner, dear.
Whatever!
Just be quick!
Woah!
Not looking too good!
No, he's not!
We really should feel sorry for him.
He never fully got over his parent's death.
It left him wide insane.
Oh my god, massie drop!
Thank you for the fifty!
Get the ships!
Thank you!
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
He's gone.
How does he know am I dead to me?
Cut me free!
Oh!
Am I using my Bruce Wayne voice?
No, put me back, I wanna be the Joker.
Oh!
Oh, what?
I don't...
How the fuck was I supposed to know?
Rest in peace, Bruce Wayne!
Oh shit!
How the fuck was I supposed to know I was supposed to die?
Whoa!
Wait, what?
I thought it was still a cutscene!
I thought we were still in a cutscene!
Are you okay, Batman?
He is not okay.
Am I... what am I...
I guess I'll fly here.
Oh shit, I don't know where to fly to.
Did I exploit it?
No.
What?
Oh, line?
Oh, I have my gadgets!
I didn't know I had my gadgets.
I didn't know I had my gadgets with me.
I thought like...
What are you doing, little bat?
Okay, it's time.
Go up.
Go up!
What?
How?
I was so fast!
Come on!
That was bullshit.
That was fucking bullshit.
What?
Oh my god!
Okay, that was also bullshit.
Okay, here you go.
It's a joke!
There is no middle stick!
You...
You fuckers, I actually thought I fucked up.
I actually thought I fucked up.
I was like, I thought you made like middle button.
You know, like the middle mouse button?
I was like, oh my god!
You mean I can dodge?
You fucker, I actually thought I fucked it up.
Gotta get him out of here.
I was like, no!
There was a middle mouse button!
No!
I actually did crash!
God damn it!
No!
The real crash!
But holy shit, the Joker glitch thing actually scared the shit out of me.
I was like, what the fuck?
I was like, oh my god!
Is my PC actually done for real real now?
I was like, oh fuck!
Maybe my PC is finally rest in peace for reals.
Maybe if I had a middle stick button.
Okay, where did it leave me off?
Where did I die?
Okay, it's not that bad.
Okay, thank god.
Oh my god, thank god.
I actually hit a safe point.
Am I stuck there?
Wait!
Am I?
Oh my god, am I locked?
No way!
Okay, there's no way!
There's no way I'm fucked right now!
Cheater, thank you for the superchat!
Thank you, thank you!
Hello!
There's no way.
There's no fucking way I would, I cannot progress!
No, no, no.
There's no way I'm softlocked, please!
Please!
Middle bass button, where are you?
Where are you?
Okay.
Okay, there's no way I'm actually softlocked here.
There's no fucking way.
Okay.
Wait.
I'm out of here.
I'm out of here!
We're okay!
We're okay, we're okay, we're okay!
We're okay, guys!
We made it past that one area!
Thank you, this is rich.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, thank fucking god.
We're so back.
We're so back, we're so back.
We are so back.
Shit.
I don't know why.
Climb.
Climb!
Okay, it's not over yet.
It's not over.
Okay.
I can't because you're the scarecrow for a reason!
Climb, please.
Oh god, okay.
You ain't killing me, I'm you!
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
Oh, thank god.
Oh, thank god, okay.
Can you make sure I don't die here?
Bro, this trip is freaking me out, bro.
Okay.
Nice.
Huh?
No!
No, I have to do this again!
No, scarecrow!
This is not good for my brain.
My brain chemistry in the end.
There's no way that the scarecrow toxins is like good for the brain.
What are the long-term effects from the fear toxins?
Like, like brain chemistry wise.
Yeah, I'm...
This is a very bad trip right now.
I just punch you in...
Oh.
They're just skeletons.
Wait, are you like...
Do I need a batter-arm you?
Are you gonna charge?
Are you the batter-arm skeletons?
Oh, he is the batter-arm skeletons.
Wait, wait!
Hahaha!
It still works.
Guys, it still works!
Guys!
It still worked!
Okay.
It's still...
It's still okay.
Like, I still got it.
Okay.
That's failed successfully.
I don't think I was supposed to know!
I didn't know!
Hahaha!
I didn't already batter-arm'd him!
Really dodged him.
I'm alive still.
Yeah!
Easy.
Bring me back to the Joker.
Oh my god, you have eyes!
More!
Bro!
What the fuck is wrong with me?
Did I like get used to it?
Bro, I think like...
I'm just like so used to toxins now.
Yes!
I'm bat-bat.
Alright, nice.
We can love-love.
Alright, what do we get?
Guys?
What should our upgrades be, guys?
We already have remote batter-arm'd!
Did you not see that all the times I fucking...
was successfully able to...
hit people with my batter-arm'd?
Twin batter-arm'd?
Okay, I'll get twin.
How do I do this?
So like, aim, L, T, N, R, T?
Okay.
Nice.
That should be okay.
Okay.
Nice.
That should be okay.
It's this way.
Guys, all the times I've successfully, you know...
hit my targets...
Brain's got the brain.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god, he has eyes!
Did I just drop down?
It'll be alright if I just drop down, right?
What will happen if I just...
fall down?
Yeah, see?
It'll be fine.
Like, why am I scared?
I can just do this and then...
Easy!
Look at that!
What's down there?
Killer Croc Cell.
Hell, you first restored.
Same difference.
No one goes in and comes out again.
Oh, here.
There's stairs.
So why is Scarecrow going down there?
Alright, don't worry.
I can use my double batarangs for this.
Watch this.
Bam!
Look at that!
Get over here!
You can't five second roll!
No gun!
Five second roll!
Alright.
Look at that.
I told you.
Successfully!
I told you I can do this successfully.
Oh, this is when she was Harley and Quinzel?
Oh yeah, like no doctor has ever said that.
Damn Joker.
He's such a Rizzly.
Oh my god.
He knows how to charm a woman!
If he was a streamer, he would have so much Akasupas.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Depending on the version of Toxin, Harley uses it recreationally.
Makes sense.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
I'm pretty sure I built like a tolerance or some shit by then.
What is this?
A scan?
No.
Thank you, Batman, for the Akasupa!
I feel like...
You know what?
I feel like if he streamed this crime, he would have so many fans on the dark web.
Alright, let's see.
Hacking time.
It's like how women and men send letters to...
Wait, what the fuck?
What?
How am I not getting... Okay.
You know how some women and men send love letters to serial killers in prison?
He'd be able to find somebody.
Oh no, oh no, oh no.
I can't find it.
I can't.
Last few seconds.
Nice.
Yeah!
A lot of serial killers have wives and...
have outside wives and husbands.
There was this famous...
There was a murderer or something that was on trial.
And then... I don't know if it was a guy or a girl.
I think it was fangirls were like, Oh my god!
He's so hot!
He can't be a murderer!
Look at him!
He's just misunderstood!
He's so hot though!
And I'm just like, what the fuck is...
I'm just...
I'm just like, what the fuck?
Bro!
No, it wasn't.
It was someone recent.
I can fix him!
Even though he murdered so many women, he wouldn't murder me.
Like, what the fuck?
Holy shit!
Bro.
Like, please.
Okay, it's bullet time.
Wait, I don't need a bullet.
I can use two...
Nice.
Okay, I can keep doing it.
Oh, he's getting guns!
I forgot!
Oh!
That's right.
No guns.
Okay.
There's no guns.
I can fly.
It does... It happens a lot more...
Like, a lot more frequently than you expect.
Get out.
No gun.
This is a fair match.
That's fucking right.
Get over here.
Get over here!
Oh, shit.
It's okay.
Gotta dodge all these guys.
Nice.
Throw.
Throw!
Okay.
We gotta get him out of here.
I can't do a takedown!
They're all trying to get the gun!
No.
No gun for you!
No!
There's too many people!
Yes!
Okay.
One of you guys would let me do a finish, right?
Nice.
We're fine.
Why can't I get a gun?
I know, like, I keep asking about it, but I just want gun.
Like, it can be a non-lethal gun.
You know?
Like, it's a bullet that just stops, like...
That just, like, pinches the skin.
And it hurts a little bit.
Like, it stuns you.
Yeah, stun gun.
Stun guns aren't lethal!
Batman, why can't I have a bat-a-gun?
A bat-a-stun!
Yeah!
Stun guns aren't lethal!
That's different!
Alright.
Is there anything here that I need to look at?
Ooh!
The Riller.
You do know how to read a map, don't you?
Um...
Okay, actually, maybe not.
Mmm... Good question!
Good question!
Here?
Yeah, it's here.
What a great question.
Wait, what?
Where am I?
Whoa!
I'm in cash.
And you?
In your dream.
Not you.
Now.
I don't think, like... I feel like as a guard, you would want to be, like, nice to them.
So, like, because, like, they're always breaking out, right?
So they're always breaking...
You know they're always breaking out.
There's no, like, if they break out.
It's, like, whenever they do break out.
So, like, I feel like at that point, you'd want to be nice to them.
So, like...
So, why would you, like, you know, be antagonistic to them when you know they're gonna fucking break out?
Like...
All I'm saying...
is that eventually...
Eventually they're gonna get out.
My game crashed.
So, like, why would you ever be, like, antagonistic to them?
Why would you be antagonistic to the villains?
What?
Okay.
But, like, if you're more mean to them, then they'll be...
Like, they're gonna, like, you know, they're gonna kill you anyway.
Okay.
So, like, you're going and thinking these villains are gonna kill you anyway.
But, like, if you're, like, extra mean to them, then they're gonna make it more painful.
More slow and painful.
You know?
So if you're nice to them, they'll be like, you know what?
You were nice to me.
We'll let it end quick.
You know?
It'll be quick.
But instead, because Cash was being a crock, now he doesn't have a hand.
Huh?
I feel like the water's already tainted.
The amount of Joker shit in there.
Oh no, not the water.
Oh shit!
Wait, so can I eat him?
Oh!
Making access to the killer crocs there.
Where is that?
Okay, it's this way.
Oh my.
Okay, I don't think he can breathe down there.
So, like, he couldn't be...
He might as well be dead.
I don't know.
I don't know if he could actually, like, breathe down... like...
No!
I can't swim?
What are you, fucking Sonic?
God damn it.
I can't swim, guys.
Why can't you swim?
Perfect time for the underwear gas mask.
Thank you for the super chat, Jonathan.
Thank you, thank you.
What's the point if you can't swim, Batman?
This is why Aquaman's on the team?
Is he your, like, token swim boy?
Can't swim so you got Aquaman?
He's carrying too much muscle, Doki.
You don't understand.
There's nothing on record.
Bruce, are you sure about this?
Sounds like a suicide mission.
Holy shit, Doki.
No one cares about Aquaman until the Aquaman move... until, like...
What's his name?
Jason Samoa fucking played Aquaman?
Croc's just an animal.
And animals just need traps and the right bait.
I'll be fine.
Oh shit, that's a bigger fucking...
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, sorry, Momoa.
I'm sorry.
Jason Momoa.
Giving away my position to Croc.
I'll need to move as slowly as possible.
Whoa, where is he?
But all I'm saying, no one cared about him until Jason Momoa was...
Until Jason Momoa was Batman.
Not Batman, was...
Was Aquaman.
But I'm saying,
I'll be fine.
What's he gonna do?
Eat me?
Poop, poop, poop, poop, poop, poop, poop, poop.
You want... I remember he wanted to, like...
He was auditioning for another...
Hello?
Am I back?
Oh no, I'm refreshing.
I'm...
I don't know if I'm back.
But okay!
Okay, give me a sec.
I need a...
Guys!
I have to... I'm on WiFi.
I don't know...
If like...
I don't know what's going on with my... with my connection.
I'm on WiFi now.
Oh my god.
I can't believe I'm on WiFi.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Give me a sec.
I'm trying to...
I'm not... I'm not alive.
On screen right now.
I'm on WiFi right now.
So give me a sec, everybody.
Give me a sec.
Holy shit.
I can't believe I'm on WiFi.
I can't believe I've been on WiFi in fucking forever.
Holy shit.
Alright, let's see.
I'm connecting.
Please.
Connect.
How could I?
What do you mean I can't connect?
What do you mean?
Imagine thinking of Super Chat.
Thank you.
Maybe the WiFi is the ransom mail.
I can't believe I'm on fucking WiFi.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Alright.
How do I do this?
Connect.
Why are you not connecting?
Is it because I'm on WiFi?
Guys.
I'm trying to figure this out.
This is Jason Momoa's doing it all because I talked about Jason Momoa.
I blame Jason Momoa.
I fucking blame him.
It's all...
It's his fucking fault.
What the fuck?
What happened to my direct connection?
What actually happened?
Bro!
Why can't I connect with a PC?
What do you mean?
What do you mean I can't connect to this?
What is my...
Alright.
Let's see.
What the fuck is this?
Okay.
Alright.
Maybe if I change my thing here.
Guys.
Technical difficulties right now.
We are experiencing some turbulence at the moment.
So...
Give me a sec.
Oh!
I'm alive!
There we go.
I figured it out.
It's WiFi gaming time.
I can't believe I'm on WiFi now.
Alright.
Here we go.
I am on WiFi.
Let's hope that this will be okay.
Oh!
Why you told me to run?
What the fuck?
I forgot about running.
Oh my god.
I don't know what... what...
what went wrong.
But we are going to be WiFi gamers until we...
Until my direct connection comes back.
Alright.
Where am I?
Here?
I'm going to go here, right?
No.
I go here.
We go here.
Okay.
I have to run again.
Yep.
Here I go.
Alright.
Don't worry.
I'll... I'll fucking fix chat later.
There were so many things going around.
It's WiFi meta now.
Okay.
It's okay.
Throw a batteram.
Why do I need to throw a batteram?
Why?
Okay.
That's not a batteram.
That's not a batteram!
I kept looking at my...
That's a good thing.
It's a good thing.
Because then that means...
Because then that means I can fix the chat.
You know?
That's what I wanted to do.
I wanted to fix chat.
Guys.
It's good.
It's alright.
Okay.
We're back.
We're fucking back.
Oh.
Whoops.
Okay.
Nice.
We did it.
There we go.
I figured it out.
Guys.
Here we go.
Everything is fine.
We figured it all out.
Nothing to worry about.
Like we never left.
There we go.
Easy.
So easy.
Back computer.
Everything is gold.
It's like anything wrong can happen.
That's happening.
It's happening today.
Nice.
Let me gather this.
My computer is slowly dying.
My internet is slowly dying too.
My internet
is slowly dying too.
We're here for the ride.
Am I halfway through this game yet?
Murphy's Law and Fall in fact.
Oh.
There it is.
Right here.
Wait.
What?
Oh.
What do you mean?
I missed.
Curve.
Batman.
Why did it curve, Batman?
Why did it curve?
Why the fuck?
You don't need to curve the bullet.
Wait.
What is this behind me?
Okay.
There we go.
Doctor says it's normal to curve.
Okay.
Nice.
I actually don't even know how much...
You guys are giving me so many conflicting answers.
I actually don't even know how much I have left.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh my god.
Alright.
There you go.
I trust my doctor.
I feel like I can just crouch walk.
It's faster.
There you go.
Let me say my percent, doctor.
Wait.
I can actually finish this today.
Okay.
Thank god.
Technically I can finish this today.
If it's 75%.
Alright.
We're in it for the long haul.
We went through so many things together, guys.
Why did he go that way?
Okay.
I was like, why?
I mean, that's fine.
Yeah.
I was like, why did he go that way?
Got her.
Hey, what is that?
Is he stupid?
Alright.
Come on.
Face me.
Nice.
No.
I thought he was going to take me back into the pit.
Alright.
Yay.
This way.
What?
Not this way?
I can find you, Batman.
I mean, it's not that hard.
Oh.
Boop.
This way.
I'm just going to cut this real quick.
I mean, it's not that difficult to find me.
Just like poke your head out a little bit and you'll see me.
Oh no.
What is he going to do?
Fucking come up and bite me?
He smells my Wi-Fi connection.
I guess I use the...
I use this?
Hmmmm.
I guess I use the...
Okay.
Wait.
Hold A to run.
Why?
Which way?
Am I going the right way?
Oh.
Okay.
I was like, What do you mean run?
Where?
Oh there.
No!
Oh shit!
Okay.
It hit it.
I was going to be like, where did my batarang...
Okay.
My batarang hit the wall, but it still counted.
That's okay.
I take those.
What?
Run?
No!
No no no no no no no no no no no no no!
Okay.
This way.
Oh my god.
This is so scary.
I'm so paranoid right now.
He could come up at any time.
Okay.
Got her.
Nice.
Yeah.
How much fucking spores do I have to get her?
Alright.
Oh thank god.
Thank fucking god.
Okay.
Nice.
Yeah, I don't think he'll be a problem.
You're right, Batman.
He doesn't see...
Whoa whoa whoa!
What the wrong way?
It was this way.
I think?
Yeah.
It's this way.
Wait.
Huh?
Please open that door!
For me!
Thank you!
Thank you, I really appreciate that.
Thank you so... God damn it.
I hate these.
Alright, as I was saying...
Jason Momoa wanted to...
wanted to be a different guy.
Oh, he wanted to be...
What's his name?
Oh my god!
Oh shit!
No, no, no, no, no!
I'm trying to think!
He wanted to be this anti-hero guy.
What's his name?
He... he...
Lobo!
Yes!
He would make a really good Lobo.
He's a fucking nerd.
I didn't even realize...
Oh my god, these...
No, no, no, no, no, no!
He got the bad line!
No, I meant Jason.
He's actually a nerd.
And I'll do it again!
Jason Momoa, thank you for the Akasupa.
No, I didn't do...
Are you fucking kidding me?
I had to do this all the way from the beginning?
Fuck you, Jason Momoa!
But thank you for the Akasupa.
You're an Akasupa.
Oh my god.
God damn it.
That's it.
Can't believe it.
I got fucked over because I had the line.
Alright.
I'm good now.
Everything's fine.
Okay.
That should be all the explosions.
Can't believe I had to do this all the way back from the beginning.
Where is he gonna pop up?
I'm so paranoid.
There you go.
Just in case.
God damn it.
I'm so far.
I still have 300 left!
Please!
Why can't I send my Batcave over?
Imagine.
My Batcar.
Just fucking grab my Batcar into the sewers.
God damn it.
Okay.
Then I go...
Nope.
This way?
Okay.
It's this way.
No.
No no no no no!
This way.
Okay.
I'm retracing my steps.
I remember now.
I remember how to get back.
Nice.
Alright.
I remember exactly how to get back now.
Nope.
I remember exactly how to get back.
Now.
Now I do.
You can't run from me.
It's not gonna stop me from running.
That's not gonna stop me from running.
Oh my god.
It's Crash Bandicoot time.
Why did you stop, Bebe?
Okay.
Now.
Oh my god.
Batman is faster than the camera.
I hate this.
Okay.
We're good.
Oh.
We're not good.
It's okay.
I can time this perfectly.
Woo!
Nice.
I knew there was gonna be water underneath so it's not killing.
I'm feeling...
Nice!
Yay!
Alright.
I'm gonna take this as a win and I'm gonna use a bathroom break.
I'll be right back.
Where is this?
I am here.
This is the Batcave.
Alright.
I'm gonna take this as a win and go for a bathroom break.
I'll be right back guys.
I'm back!
Okay, who the fuck just said chat you wanna kiss by the sewer?
Please love yourself more.
What the fuck?
Please have some standards!
Holy shit!
Okay.
Guys, you need to have standards guys.
Cause then that- cause you're watching me and I assume you guys have high standards, right guys?
Cause if you have low standards and you're watching me, then that makes me a little sad.
I'm like, that says a lot of- Guys, you have high standards, right?
Guys!
Alright, what do we upgrade?
What's the next- I guess Bataran power.
You know what?
Yeah, Bataran power.
Okay.
Um... did I go the wrong way?
I went the wrong way.
Fuck, okay.
It's this way.
Yeah, just enough I think.
Guys!
Okay, this way.
Weeeeee!
It was not this way guys.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I'm cheesing the system?
I'm cheesing it?
But...
Yay!
Maybe I'll- Yes!
I did it!
What?
Nice.
I cheesed it.
Perfectly.
Nice.
Perfectly cheesed.
As all things should be.
Alright, let's see.
Where do we go?
Oh, it's this place.
It's this way.
Alright.
Gotta go ahead this way.
Oh shit!
Hey guys!
Whoa!
Guys!
Come on!
I have two batter-ends.
Oh, this is the wrong battering!
Now I have two batter-ends.
No!
This is the wrong one again!
Oh, damn it.
Let me just get rid of this guy.
Alright, nice.
And not see all of these people.
What's up guys?
Wait, you have a gun?
Oh my god.
Don't worry.
Dark Souls slide.
Oh, I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die.
Awesome!
Joyboys, welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome!
Detective, yes, we have standards.
What the fuck are you doing with this box?
Oh no, a toaster.
What will we do?
Oh no, he's grabbing the gun.
He's grabbing the gun.
Yeah.
Detective Shade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yes, we have standards.
But if a homie asks for a kiss, need a serious?
And then the homie will get a kiss.
I'm serious.
Thank you for the super chat, Shane.
Thank you, thank you.
The plants are going crazy.
I'm getting...
It's okay.
I've got the mold samples.
I'm heading to the Batcave to mix up the antidote.
That's true.
You can't reject a homie.
I know you're in a hurry, but I'm sure you know what you're doing.
Bing.
Even a fan of $100 foie gras can enjoy a $12 bucket of...
I'm the foie gras, right?
I'm the duck you fucking force fed and then ate the liver of, right guys?
Right?
All right.
I am, right?
Guys.
Needa, no.
Scan and opus.
All right, this way.
I'm in the Batcave.
That's definitely not OSHA approved.
Oh, wow.
Where am I getting all this... is this where all the power bill went to?
Wait, you're right.
Who built this?
Wait, you guys are right!
Who the fuck built this?
Did it have like workers and the A?
Johnson, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I just got back.
What in the world is going on right now?
Did my fucking... I swear to god, did my wifi die again?
No, we're still alive.
I'm just not alive.
Oh shit, I got an upgrade though.
Fires up to three claws.
I can't allow structural weaknesses to be pulled down remote.
Okay, give me a sec.
We're going through a lot today.
Batman is so... I used up all my luck in Power World, clearly.
I feel like at this point, I definitely used up all my luck in Power World.
Everything that could go wrong has gone wrong today.
Give me a sec.
I'm barely connecting right now.
Oh my god.
Guys, give me a sec.
We're going back in.
I think.
Connect.
Yes, I am still on the wifi.
I am indeed still on the wifi right now.
It's been pretty rough today.
It's okay, I got third place.
Plus one.
In Power World.
It's something.
No!
I can't connect!
I don't understand!
How could the wifi do this to me?
Oh my god.
How could the wifi do this?
I've been nothing but great to the wifi!
Do I just use... Am I going to actually use my data?
Am I?
Oh my god.
I don't understand how they could do this to me.
Okay.
I've been nothing but...
I've been nothing but like amazing to my PC.
What have I done wrong?
Okay.
I need to make sure I don't accidentally read out my IP.
I'm like...
Okay, Doki.
Do not read this out when you're typing this in.
Wifi giveth and wifi taketh.
I don't understand.
How could this happen to me?
I just want to beat Batman!
Please!
Just let me beat the game!
I'm so close to beating the game!
At least we...
You know, at least we stopped at a good point.
You know?
At least you get to see that.
At least you get to see...
Now we're beating Batman today!
Oh my god.
I'm in!
I'm back in!
I'm back in, guys!
Everyth... Oh my god.
Everything is okay.
Okay.
Everything is okay everybody.
We're back in it.
Wait, not this one.
We're back in it guys, look.
Look, we're back in it.
Everything is fine.
Here we go.
Alright, wait, I forgot to...
I need to tap back into my chat.
Okay.
Nice.
That's it, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We gotta stop Poison Ivy now.
How do I get out of here?
I guess like here?
That's what I'm saying.
Okay, anyway, that's what I was saying.
Who the fuck built this?
Like...
Are you guys as confused as me?
I don't know.
Who built this?
Alright, I guess this way.
There's no way Bruce Wayne did this.
Like...
Yeah, he beats up people.
But like, he does not have the fucking...
He does not have like the work ethics to build this.
God damn it.
There's no way to let Alfred build this.
He's fucking old.
Oh.
Oh, okay, here we go.
Oh, I can finally do that wall.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
He built multiple by himself?
Oh, okay.
Here we go.
Oh, I can finally do that wall.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Bro, okay, labrum...
Nice kick, Batman.
There's no way he built this by himself.
Jason Momoa built it and painted it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh yeah, Alfred beats super .
I saw it.
I've seen that comic before.
He got like, kryptonite.
Like, those like...
You know those mob wrist...
brace or whatever?
But then it's like kryptonite.
Alfred does not have the engineer degree to build a fucking Batcave.
Like, there's... I refuse to believe that he has the degree to fucking...
the engineer degree to build a Batcave.
Where do I go from here?
Sure he does.
Guys, I know you're all Alfred fanboys.
But like, you guys have to think real fast.
Guys, think for a second, please.
He can get one.
Yes, but that doesn't mean he's qualified to fucking build a Batcave.
Alfred's Mike Kamioshi.
It's true.
I just googled it.
Then that makes me like less trustworthy of the Batcave.
He doesn't even have a degree for this.
How can I trust him to build a fucking structure in a cave?
Alfred's a homie?
Well, he's fucking dead.
Like...
Do you not remember what I established?
He's not even...
He's been dead for five years!
Here I go.
I'm called for.
Here?
I'm just back here.
Isn't this the original cave?
No, this is different.
Too soon!
But it's different.
You guys had to know this sooner or later.
Because I said it during the part one.
He won't be when they reboot it.
Okay, that's true.
That's true.
You're not wrong.
You're not wrong, guys.
Don't worry.
When they reboot it.
That man literally chose to build a getaway home under asylum.
Yes, but who?
There's no way.
I'm not sure.
Bruce Wayne built this by himself.
I refuse to believe Bruce Wayne built this by himself.
He didn't even finish school!
He went and learned martial arts.
Lucius Fox is underrated.
He helped with the gadgets and stuff.
Yeah, they really get one guy to build the fucking...
Oh my god, it's time to fist this plant.
He borrowed some tools.
Like...
Now I'm scared!
Because he's more likely to build a fucking sinkhole.
They won't get that far.
My antidote will stop them.
Alright.
Poki, please.
He's a billionaire.
Even the Batcave?
That's fucked up.
Okay.
That's fucked up that he got two elderly people to build his fucking home.
Hahaha!
I feel like that's even worse.
Oh shit.
Fist.
Alright.
Ow!
Where did I go?
Where am I?
Okay, I need to figure out how to get up there.
Where are the plants?
He made kids build his fucking Batcave?
Hahaha!
I was gonna say Robins helped with building...
Bro!
The elderly and the kids?
We need to stop him.
Somebody stop Batman.
Bad.
Alright.
I think it's like...
Am I close to the fucking area yet?
No, I have to get head up.
No.
Who's gonna stop him, Joker?
No one can stop him.
Game.net, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you, Batman Facts.
Batman builds a Batman with the help of Alfred, Robin and Harold.
Batman's tech guide.
Wayne tells a construction crew he's building a scenic cave and then they haul it out and assemble the mechanical bits.
Oh my god, he's gonna poison the water supply again!
Also, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't believe it!
He got kids!
And the other league!
Who's gonna stop him?!
Alright, fist.
Why does this look like a... Why is this cave shaped like a bat?
That's weird.
Ow.
Where did I go?
This way?
Where the fuck is the...
God, there's so many areas.
Did I go the wrong way?
This way?
Bro, where the fuck is the exit?
Okay, it's like here.
It's below me, I think.
Yeah, it's right here.
Okay, thank god.
I... this was where I came from.
This is...
Thank god, fucking...
Alright, let's do this again.
I...
No...
Nooo!
I went down!
I went down.
Oh my god.
I can't believe I went down.
This is because I'm on wifi.
Even my fucking brain cells have gone down with the wifi.
Gamers don't look up cars.
No!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god, I'm back in the beginning?
Okay, I can fast travel.
I can speedrun this.
I blame the wifi.
If I wasn't on wifi, things would be easier.
It's never my fault.
It's the wifi's fault.
Alright, here we go.
This way.
Then we go up.
Just don't fall, please Batman.
Do not fall!
Up I go!
Okay.
Oh my god!
That's where the up was.
I noticed the up now.
I noticed it.
It's up here.
It's up here guys.
I figured it out.
I'm so sad.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
On this episode, Doki gets lost again.
Okay.
Where?
Here.
Alright.
Boop.
Oh thank god there's a Riller trophy to tell me where.
Joker?
Is that Joker?
Joker, please!
Let me listen to your voice so I don't get lost!
How the fuck do I get up there?
Huh?
Can I... Can I do it from... from the claw?
Wait.
Oh!
Boop!
Nice.
Bat claw time.
Yay!
Come over here!
Make a... make a bridge!
I mean I could do this.
Make a bridge for me!
God damn it.
I wanted to make a bridge.
Wait how the... how the fuck do I get over there still?
Instructions?
Instructions unclear.
Alright.
Obviously not this.
Grapple and... Can I grapple up now?
Oh now I can!
Okay.
I didn't realize I could grapple now.
Yes!
Yay!
What the fuck?
Where did you come from?
Holy shit!
I'm so blind.
Alright!
Thank you for the five!
Give the ship!
Thank you!
Oh for the love of... I suppose that's you in there, Bat.
Well enjoy it while you can!
These caves will be your tomb.
Wait he stopped moving just like me when I was on the Wi-Fi.
Alright up we go.
Open the door.
Don't worry.
I have this.
Whoop whoop!
Yay!
Concussion!
Nice.
I'm happy now.
Endercon?
Teef!
Alright.
Oh fuck that's a lot of things.
Okay.
Baska!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Joki!
What CP model do you use?
I know I have stability issues due to unoptimized bias setting.
Maybe a mem test as well?
You may want to get your settings checked.
Great stream by the way.
Good question!
Teef!
Wait!
Alright let's see.
Where do I go?
Do they see me?
Wait!
It's not my crutch!
But there's a gargoyle!
It's not my crutch I swear!
But now I got the gargoyle!
Gargoyle!
I don't think he saw me.
Goodbye!
Nice.
Gargoyle!
Yay!
Okay wait I can do this again.
I can do this again.
Here I go again.
Gargoyle!
How many gargoyles can I get away with?
Let me make my pile!
Pile.
This...
My gargoyle pile!
Okay I'll put it here.
No!
My gargoyle pile!
Go over there!
Yes right here!
Right here!
Yes!
Go to the pile!
Where are you?
Goodbye!
Don't look up.
Don't look up though.
Just head to the pile!
You know you want to!
Come on!
Oh whoops!
Get to the pile!
I'm sure it came from over there!
Yes it did!
No!
Not there!
Fucking...
I'm fucking gonna kill him.
Dude fuck this.
My beautiful pile.
Maybe there's still one more.
Let's go!
There's still one more.
He'll eventually come over here, right?
Come to the pile!
Please!
Report to the pile!
It's so cool!
You know, I'll make this pile.
This is my new pile.
My new pile.
Oh shit!
There's one more?
We have... Whoa!
Guys, there was a lot of people still alive.
If it works, it works!
There's a lot... That's okay!
One HP in the dream again!
I made a new pile.
Did you guys like my new pile?
Pile number two.
My pile.
Alright, what was the riddle for this?
Riddle me this.
Oh hey, there's a thing here.
Nice.
Seriously, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The concussion won't kill him, but the medical... That's what I'm saying!
Like, this is much worse than like not killing.
Because now you're giving him like medical debt.
In America.
And I'm pretty sure like... Because like...
It's a superhero area too.
So like... Like the insurance is like...
Even worse than normal insurance.
And I feel like the medic... Oh my gosh.
Stop.
The doctor must be so fucking nice.
Because all the people that are like need doctors.
Riddle me this.
Wait, that's why Batman owns like a pharmacy.
Did you guys know Batman also owns a pharmacy?
Oh my god!
That's so fucked up, Batman.
Batman, that's pretty fucked up.
He is part of the problem.
He is actually part of the problem.
Holy shit.
I never realized that.
Anything to scan here?
It all adds up.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
It's time for hacking time.
Okay, where's the other one?
Nice.
Two.
Last one.
Oh no.
Why is the last one always the hardest?
Where is it?
Oh, here it is.
Nice.
The Batman infinite money glitch.
It's like the infinite chocolate glitch but for money.
Nice.
How do I solve this riddle?
What was this riddle again?
What was this one's riddle?
Blow up the floor?
No, there's nothing there.
No, no.
Batman doesn't own everything.
Because for some fucking reason, Gotham has like 200 fucking billionaires that live here.
Like every villain or hero here is either a billionaire villain or a billionaire hero.
What?
I hear people.
Oh, there they are.
It's the new Silicon Valley.
Alright.
Boop.
Oh, wait.
That's not what I wanted.
Boop.
There you go.
Get down over here.
Boop.
Nice.
There's a vent?
It's in the vent?
The riddle?
Okay.
Is it in this vent?
Ow.
Sorry.
Where's the riddle?
What's this?
Where am I?
I don't know where I am.
Where's this place?
Where the fuck am I?
Oh, I'm in this other event area.
Gotham City is either where all the rich people live or where all the poor people live.
There's no middle class in Gotham City.
If you think about it.
Alright.
I don't know where the riddle is for this one.
Oh, well.
I think we have to go back this way.
Alex, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I swear to God.
I swear to fucking God.
My Wi-Fi.
Wi-Fi.
Why you must do this to me, Wi-Fi?
Oh,
you fuck.
Please!
Let me beat Batman!
That's all I want!
I'm so close to beating Batman!
Oh my God!
I'm so fucking close!
No, it's just...
Okay, I'm back.
I'm fucking back.
I swear to fucking God.
Wi-Fi, please.
Please, Wi-Fi!
Here we go.
That should be it.
Is it this?
No.
Here we go.
Oh my God.
Wi-Fi!
So Batman, I have time to beat up.
I crashed.
I will beat you!
I will beat you, Batman!
I will beat you so I never have to deal with this again!
Oh my God!
Get down, you Jason Momoa!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Are you sure?
Thank you for the super chat.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Sounds like Mexico.
All right, here we go.
No!
We will beat Batman!
That's what I'm talking about.
Part four!
And deal with this another day.
Here we go.
This is it.
Where am I?
I swear... Okay, thank God.
Oh, thank fucking God.
I was going to say, I swear to God, if I have to do that one area again.
Okay.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Tomato PC upgrade fun.
You do not listen to me!
Okay, it's either getting hurt by Batman or getting hurt...
I feel like I would get hurt by Joker rather than...
No, get hurt by Batman rather than Joker.
But Joker would actually make it slow and painful.
Tee!
The year is 2055.
Doki is finally at the final 10% of Batman.
Will this be the year?
Dad, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
He held him upside down and beat the crap out of him.
I mean, I just need to get this guy.
No, I need you to get the guy with the gun!
The gun!
Oh my God!
I'll just kill him.
It's the gun!
The gun guy!
Ow.
Okay, it's fine.
I got the gun.
It's okay.
We got the gun.
We got the gun, guys.
That's okay.
Okay.
We're good.
We're okay.
Everything is fine.
Panda, welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Jesus Christ!
Get away!
No,
no, no, no, no!
Okay.
Got it counted correctly.
Nice.
All right.
Get him out.
No.
What are you... What?!
I counted it!
I swear.
I know I got shanked.
I got fucking shanked.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe I got shanked.
Okay.
I'll use the rumor control.
You know what?
No, I have an idea.
There we go.
That's fucking right.
What are you gonna do now?
Nothing!
That's right.
You can't do it.
Woo!
Yeah!
I forgot he had... Sorry.
I forgot he had a gun.
I forgot he had a gun, guys.
There's no way.
I think I can... I think I can kill them with a bat.
I don't know.
I think I can kill them with a batarang.
Woop.
There we go.
I think I can kill them with a batarang.
No, they're all very alive.
They're all... They're all very alive, guys.
Alright.
We can do this.
Okay.
Okay, we can... we can do this.
Okay, we can totally do this.
Okay, here we go.
God damn it, we can do this!
Alright, get over here!
Gun!
There we go.
It's fine.
I told you we could do this!
I told you!
Come on.
Dodge!
There, he can't get another gun!
I told you!
Ah, he shanked me!
Alright, this is not good though.
The shank is not good.
Okay, nice.
I messed up the combo for that, but that's okay.
That's alright.
And I dodged.
It's okay, I still have plenty of HP.
Nope!
No shanking, no shanking, no shank... Oh shit!
No gun.
Yeah, I think he's okay.
Don't worry.
I think he'll be okay.
See, I told you!
I got this!
Nope.
No gun.
There we go.
Watch.
Easy.
First try.
Nice.
We did it!
Alright.
And then... is it hacking time?
Hacking time.
Time to play on my phone.
Time to play on my PSP.
Oh.
PSP?
This is why PSP was discontinued.
Surely they have healthcare in Gotham.
Thank you Ken.
Thank you Super Chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Another hacker man.
Hacker man time.
Yeah, thank you Super Chat.
Thank you.
Thank you!
Hello Doki.
Have you heard of the legend of the Mad and his adventures at the Ham Asylum?
Welcome to the Madhouse.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Uh... Alright, where do we go?
Oh wait, I can upgrade.
Alright, what to upgrade?
Oh, I'm like...
I think I'm gonna upgrade... Uh... Triple Batarangs!
Battleground...
I think that's pretty good knowing whos.
And there!
Battleground!
LOL Isso foi uma We're gonna try again.
Save this so we can play it again.
And then...
Help us, quickly.
There is a doughnut.
There is a doughnut at the base.
Save this so we can his something to eat.
I love it.
You're hilarious.
My best attraction is... Thank you!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I'm glad you enjoyed that stream!
I've been like bumping into like a lot of fucking...
Like not fan interactions, but like a lot of random interactions.
It's been funny.
The amount of random interactions I've been getting in voice.
Niko Myoshi.
Niko's not even single!
Oh wait, there's something over there.
What's that?
Oh, there's tape!
I can love him from afar!
If you wait long enough, he will eventually be seen!
Guys!
Guys, please!
Love yourself!
Niko Myoshi platonically!
He's just a bro-doki!
Yay, teeth!
Let's see... Oh shit, what?
A bro-sheet!
Exactly!
What?
What are you sending?
Where is it?
Where is the Joker?
Is it in here?
Oh, damn it!
Oh, there he is!
There he is!
Hello!
Wait, he can dodge that?
Oh, nice.
Can I...
Damn.
Whoa!
Okay, it's okay.
There's friendly fire.
Remember our friendly fire trap.
Oh, fuck!
Okay, that was unfortunate though.
That was actually unfortunate.
Okay, get over here.
Get over here.
It's friendly fire time!
That's fucking right!
Get over here!
Yeah!
Get into the electricity!
Nice.
Free hit.
Free combo.
Free combo?
Okay, that should like actually kill them.
Like, that's a slap from this guy.
Like, come on.
He slaps pretty fucking hard.
Come on.
That should have been like easily a fucking...
Alright, here we go.
Oh, shit!
It's okay.
I have so much HP.
Ow!
Okay.
Mippy not okay.
Mippy... Oh, shit!
Mippy is not okay!
Fuck!
Please!
Okay, we'll run into electricity.
Alright, it's fine.
We're fine.
There's more?!
Oh my god!
How is there more?!
Oh no!
I didn't expect there to be more!
Woo!
Please leave me alone!
What?!
Okay.
Oh no.
Is he gonna throw bodies at me again too?
No!
Fuck!
Okay, he did.
Yep.
Yep, he did.
No!
Nice.
What?!
It's not fair.
That's not fair!
No, no, no!
Let me dodge!
Oh god!
Oh, it's a 1 HP and a Dream again!
Wow!
Please hurt each other!
Please!
Yes!
Please just hurt each other.
That's all I want.
Yes!
Okay.
Just keep hurting each other.
Let's finish this.
Woo!
Okay.
No, keep charging!
Keep charging!
It's just there!
No, no, no!
Don't use your bodies!
Do not use the bodies!
Come on!
Bowling!
Yes!
Oh god.
We can do this again.
We can do this again!
No, no, no!
Keep bowling!
The bowling will work eventually!
Woo!
Woo, woo, woo, woo!
Human dodgeball!
It's human dodgeball time!
Come on!
Woo!
Okay.
Yes!
There's too many dodge balls!
There's too many bowling pins!
What do I do?
Oh, fuck you!
There's too many bowling pins!
Oh my god!
I can't expect it anymore!
Oh please, eventually!
Okay, alright.
Technique!
Oh my god, eventually!
Eventually!
Whoa!
Okay.
Eventually there'll be less people, right?
They're counting!
Happy people forever!
There's no way!
Oh no!
Please!
Please, all this human dodge ball!
Wow!
They're infinite until you kill the giant?!
Okay, okay, this is unfortunate.
This is very unfortunate because this is very difficult.
No!
Oh my god!
Oh please!
This is so difficult to dodge!
I... I'm so sad.
We killed each other.
I'm so sad!
We killed each other but it didn't count!
Oh my god!
I can't believe it didn't count!
I can't believe it!
We were so close!
We were actually so close!
Oh my god!
What happened?!
I can't believe it!
Oh my god, wrong one!
I can't believe we were so close!
Oh my god!
No!
Not the f- No!
Oh my god!
Please let me on!
No!
Not you!
I don't care about you!
Oh my god!
Okay, there you go!
Alright.
No, no, no.
Head into the electricity!
Get into the electricity!
I don't care about the people!
Please!
If I don't kill them, it'd be easier!
Oh my god.
It'd be easier because there'd be less people to worry about!
Oh no, please.
Please, I beg of you.
Do not do this to me.
Okay.
I beg of you.
Please!
Okay.
Dodge!
Oh!
Dodge, please!
Oh, thank god!
Okay.
Do not open the elevator!
There's still people alive!
Yes.
Alright.
Oh no.
Oh no, they're gonna open the elevator!
No!
The elevator!
Not the elevator!
Oh no!
Not the fucking elevator!
It's okay.
Everything will be okay.
Everything will be okay!
Please.
Oh no, not the fucking dodgeball.
Okay.
We're fine.
We're so fine.
We're so healthy.
We're so healthy right now.
No!
Okay!
I'm... It's a strategic take!
Ow!
It's a strategic take!
It's strategic!
Please don't open the elevator.
Please, there's still people alive!
There's still people alive!
Okay.
Charge!
Woo!
What?!
Alright.
That was bullshit though.
That was actually bullshit.
Please let me... Let me on him!
Let me on him, you...
Please!
Okay.
Get away from me!
Oh, my God!
Get the fuck away from me!
Okay.
We're fine.
You guys lied to me!
You guys said they'll keep coming!
But there's clearly... They clearly keep coming no matter what!
What?
I can't believe I got one guide again.
I can't believe it.
I got one guide.
Oh my god.
I got one guide so hard.
They would always exist, but at least it's easier now.
At least it's so much easier now.
Oh my god.
Thank fucking god.
Dodge.
We're so close.
Get out of here.
Get the fuck out of here.
Leave me alone.
Leave me the fuck alone.
Nice.
Boom!
There you go.
We did it.
Oh, we fucking did it.
Please, where's my HP?
Recharge.
Why isn't my HP recharged?
Oh, thank god.
Okay, my HP recharged.
We go this way.
Okay.
Alright, we do this.
Get down.
Archie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, thank you for making me laugh so much on my birthday.
Happy birthday!
I'm glad you've been having a great time.
Oh, happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Archie.
Yeah!
Alright, where am I?
Okay, above.
Here we go.
Games, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
They're gonna try and hit you.
My advice is you don't...
I...
Okay, give me...
Don't worry, we're...
We're gonna be back soon.
Oh my god.
Wifi, why are you like this?
Wifi.
Why are you like this?
Please.
Please, what have I done?
I'm gonna use you.
Other than never use you.
Wifi.
Why?
Alright, here we go.
We're back in it.
There's apparently a scan downstairs anyway.
There is?
Like here?
Where's the scan at?
Ow.
Where do I scan?
Liars!
This scuff is so strong.
Oh, here!
It's like right here.
Gladstone, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You've got actually several hours of the game left by the way.
So it's okay to stop here if need be.
Is he lying?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Is he lying or is he speaking the truth?
How much more do I have?
I need to know.
How much more?
He's lying.
Okay.
Okay, now I don't know if you guys are lying now.
Ah, fuck.
Okay.
I still have two boss battles left?
One?
At least two?
Like 1.5?
Three hours?
I can do that.
That's fucking easy.
Okay, I need to figure out how to do this though.
How the fuck do I do this?
Oh, wait.
I tag it.
I forgot.
I have the tag.
Oop.
This is fine.
Okay, I'm gonna tag myself too.
I forgot how to...
Alright.
Boom.
How many crashes in those...
Don't say that.
Please.
Don't...
Don't say that.
What do you mean?
How many crashes?
So dead.
Nooooo.
Alright.
We'll get out of this area and we'll do the last part.
We'll do the last part another time.
We need to get outside.
Okay, we'll get outside and then...
And then we'll call it here.
Alright.
Now we're outside.
Wait, is that...
Did I save?
Okay.
We'll go to the next area and then we'll call it here.
We'll go to the next area.
You'll be walking into a trap.
That's what she thinks.
Oh, wait.
Actually, we can do this.
Let's go to the...
Let's go to the Easter egg first.
Pissed.
This island belongs to me now.
Oh, is that Ivy?
Someone says, literally an hour.
I don't...
Oh, shit.
There's four of you guys?
You know, I think that's a good time to call it.
It's alright.
The game decided this is where I'm ending.
It's okay.
The game...
We let the game decide.
We let...
It's okay, guys.
We just let the game decide to call me here.
The game said the stream is over.
Oh, my God.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It was like, no, we're done, Doki.
We are.
We are done here.
We're super fucking done here.
There's no, there's no last one.
Oh, my God.
What a wild ride.
I read a lot of super chats.
I'm not sure what happened to my cable.
I'm only on wifi right now for some fucking reason.
Even the game was like, no no no Doki, this is it.
I really wanted to finish it today too.
I knew I could finish it today.
But we were crashing way too.
It was not a good time.
The game was like, no no no.
And also the fact that I'm on wifi, I feel like we just had to stop.
But yeah, I had a great time.
I hope you guys had a great time watching today and hanging out with me.
It was definitely a really fun time.
Next week, I believe there's two collabs next week.
We're going to be playing Helldivers 2 again, but this time with a group.
Look forward to who it is.
But yes, it's going to be a full party for next week's Helldivers 2.
And then we're also going to... Lily and I are still planning a collab for next week.
We're still deciding what to do.
So I'm going to figure that out as well later.
Tomorrow is Sunday and I usually don't stream on Sunday.
So tomorrow is a break day for me.
Also, next Saturday!
On March... not March...
March 2nd will be our stream auction slash charity!
I'm really, really excited because there's a lot of really amazing things being auctioned off.
A lot of these items are one of a kind.
They are one of a kind items such as... I can actually give you guys an example.
So like one of them is like a one of a kind figure.
That's like... that's like...
That's like printed and then sent off to Japan to have it painted and everything.
And they were actually sent me like some concept art of it.
So like this is like a one of a kind figure that's going to be auctioned off.
And I'm super duper excited too.
I saw like they sent me a concept art and like being like, okay, like you want to pick this or that?
I was like, wow!
But like I'll show you guys a preview.
But yeah, this is going to be in the auction.
A lot of like amazing stuff.
So...
But they let me chose... I chose number one.
I chose one for it.
And this is going to be sent off to Japan to have it like fully painted and everything.
Before shipped over to whoever wins the auction.
But yeah, that's like some of the stuff to look forward to.
But yeah!
Thank you everybody!
Hope you guys had a fun time watching!
We will finish Batman next time!
Like next week for real!
I legit would have been able to finish it today.
If everything that...
If everything that didn't...
If I didn't go through so many things that went wrong today.
I would have finished it today.
It was so close.
We were so close to finishing it today.
But anyway...
Thank you everybody for coming.
As always everyone stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys!
Bye!